PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY AND I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE ESPECIALLY MY COLLEAGUES IN
REMEMBER BONTA WHO I'LL TURN
OVER TO AND A FEW MINUTES I'M
AND ESPECIALLY TO THOSE WHO ARE
JOINING US REMOTELY ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS WILL BE. REMOTELY
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S HEARING
A FEW LOGISTICAL NOTES BEFORE WE
BEGIN ANYONE WHO'S HERE IN THE
MEETING ROOM IS REQUIRED TO WEAR
A MASK AT ALL TIMES AND MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCE ALL TESTIMONY
TODAY WILL BE DELIVERED REMOTELY
AND THERE WILL BE TIME FOR.
PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH WILL HAPPEN
AFTER THE THIRD PANEL. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO MAKE A NOTE OF THE
USE OF GENDERED LANGUAGE
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING. WE WILL
BE DISCUSSING REPRODUCTIVE CARE
AND SCREENINGS PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THESE ISSUES DO NOT
AFFECT ALL WOMEN NOR DO THEY
AFFECT SOLELY WOMEN. TRANS WOMEN
TRANS MEN AND NON BINARY PEOPLE
ARE ALL AFFECTED IN VARIOUS
WAYS. BY THE BIRTHING AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
AND ARE OFTEN MARGINALIZED
WITHIN IT BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
CONFORM TO THE GENDER NORMS THAT
THE SYSTEM A POLLS. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THIS. AND THESE ISSUES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
CISGENDER WOMEN WITH UTERUS IS.
THAT THEY ARE BY NO MEANS
EXCLUSIVE TO THIS GROUP WE WILL
USE BOTH GENDER EXPANSIVE AND
GENDERED LANGUAGE IN THIS
HEARING. TO REFLECT THE
EXPERIENCES OF OUR PANELISTS AND
HIGHLIGHT ISSUES THAT PRIMARILY
AFFECT WOMEN. WELL RECOGNIZING
THAT THIS IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE
. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO CALL THE
HEARING TO ORDER. WHEN I WAS
FIRST ELECTED THREE YEARS AGO
ONE OF MY FIRST ACCIDENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS REQUEST THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE ON REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
. AT THE TIME. TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT AND WE'RE SEEING THE
EXTREMIST CONSERVATISM ASCENT WE
KNEW THAT WE NEEDED TO BE
PREPARED FOR REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
TO BE THREATENS. YESTERDAY WE
HEARD ORAL ARGUMENTS TO DECIDE
THE FUTURE OF ABORTION RIGHTS IN
AMERICA. WITH ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE CARE
UNDER THREAT IN OVER HALF THE
STATE'S. IT IS NOW MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT THIS
COMMITTEE CONTINUE TO OPERATE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO BE A BEACON
FOR HOPE FOR ALL AMERICAN WOMEN
BUT ALSO THAT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE TO
EVERY WOMAN IT NEEDS THAT.
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE ISSUE BY
MANY FACTORS LEGAL SOCIAL
ECONOMIC PHYSICAL AND THIS
COMMITTEE IS HERE TO EXAMINE
THESE ISSUES AND SUPPORT THOSE
SEEKING CARE IN EVERY POSSIBLE
WAY. TODAY WILL BE FOCUSED ON
CODE RED AND THE BARRIERS IT HAS
AFFECTED AND EXACERBATED WE ARE
LUCKY TO HAVE AN INCREDIBLE SET
OF PANELISTS GATHERED TOGETHER
HERE WITH US TODAY VIRTUALLY. A
RANGE OF CARE GIVERS ADVOCATES
AND EXPERTS ON THE MANY ISSUES
THAT HAVE IMPACTED REPRODUCTIVE
MATERNAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE COBY
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ISSUED TWO NEW
REALITY IN EVERY ASPECT OF LIFE
. COVERT OVERTOOK MUCH OF OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM BUT THE NEED
FOR WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE AND
HEALTH CARE NEVER STOPPED.
BABIES CONTINUE TO BE BORN.
CONTINUE TO NEED BIRTH CONTROL
WE ALL CONTINUED TO NEED TO GO
TO THE DOCTOR AND GET OUR
SCREENINGS. THE PANDEMIC HOWEVER
THREW UP INNUMERABLE OBSTACLES
TO THE PHYSICAL AND MENTAL WELL
BEING OF EVERYONE AND
PARTICULARLY WOMEN ASIAN BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND THE TEENAGE
PEOPLE. PREGNANT AND PREGNANT
PEOPLE GENERALLY. WITH ALL
ATTENTION FOCUSED ON KOBE CARE
REPRODUCTIVE AND MATERNAL HEALTH
OFTEN BECAME AN AFTERTHOUGHT
NEGLECTING THIS CARE WILL HAVE
SERIOUS LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES
AND WE'RE GOING TO LOOK INTO
THAT TODAY. THE PANDEMIC HAS
SHOWN US MORE THAN EVER THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE GOES
FAR BEYOND THE LEGAL RIGHT TO
ABORTION. WE'RE CHOOSING TO USE
THIS HEARING TO FOCUS ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IN THE
BROADEST SENSE THIS SOCIAL
MEDICAL AND MENTAL DETERMINANTS
OF HUMAN WELL BEING THAT IMPRINT
AT IMPACT REPRODUCTIVE REALITY.
THE PANDEMIC'S IMPACT HAS BEEN
BRUTALLY UNEQAL. FROM JOB
LOSSES TO CODE RATES LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED WITH
WOMEN BEARING THE BRUNT OF THE
CHILD CARE. HEALTH CARE AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC
. ON THE ECONOMIC SIDE 64% OF
KOBE JOB LOSSES WERE IN THE
SERVICE INDUSTRIES THE MAJORITY
OF WHOSE EMPLOYEES WERE PEOPLE
OF COLOR. IN THE EARLY MONTHS OF
THE PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT RATES
FOR LATINO AND BLACK WOMEN
SKYROCKET OVER TWENTY TWO
PERCENT. THREE TIMES THE RATE OF
WHITE MEN. WOMEN WERE LESS
LIKELY TO RETURN TO WORK WHEN
CHILDREN ERE STILL OUT OF
SCHOOL WITH MANY DROPPING OUT OF
THE WORKFORCE ENTIRELY. THESE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OUR HEALTH
IMPACTS THE STRESS OF THE
FINANCIAL STRAIN FOOD HOUSING
MEDICAL AND SECURITY HAS BEEN
LINKED TO SERIOUS MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL IMPACTS. REACHING FROM
DEPRESSION TO HEART DISEASE
INCREASED STRESS AND ISOLATION
IS LINKED TO INCREASES IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FACE
PARTICULAR BARRIERS TO THE
PANDEMIC. THE EPIDEMIC WHICH
PARTICULARLY IMPACTS WOMEN HAS
BEEN BRUTAL WEDNESDAY AT HOME
ORDERS AFFECT THOSE WHOSE HOMES
ARE NOT SAFE. WE WILL DISCUSS
THOSE IMPACTS THE BARRIERS AND
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS THEM
AND OUR THIRD PANEL. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AND COMPREHENSIVE
ACCESS. WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE HAVE
VOLUNTARILY DELAYED THE FIRST
MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC TO GOING
BACK AND GETTING BIRTH CONTROL
PILLS SURGERY. AND THE CARE THEY
NEED. WE KNOW THE MEDIC KALORAMA
HAS SKYROCKET DURING THE
PANDEMIC WITH ONE AND A HALF
MILLION MORE PEOPLE NOW
RECEIVING BENEFITS THAN IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. A TOTAL OF A
THIRD OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION. MEDIC HOUSE A
LANDMARK PROGRAM BUT THE
ENROLLMENT WITHOUT CORRESPONDING
INCREASES IN STAFF IS STRANGE
BACKLOG THE HOSPITALS THAT TAKE
MEDICARE OUT AND WE'LL HEAR FROM
SOME OF THOSE PROVIDERS TODAY.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS THE
MOST BASIC AND ESSENTIAL HEALTH
CARE. BUT IT IS OFTEN SEEN AS
EXTRANEOUS UNNECESSARY OR A
LUXURY. WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IN
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE WERE
OVERLOOKED IN UNDER RESOURCE
ALREADY. BUT THE PANDEMIC
RESOURCE CRUNCHES HAVE JUST
EXACERBATED THE INEQUALITIES.
WE'RE HERE TO EXAMINE HOW THE
POLICIES PLAY OUT IN THE FUTURE
WHAT IS NEEDED AS WE LOOK
FORWARD. AND WE'LL EXAMINE THREE
AREAS OF WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC DELAYED CARE
BIRTHING HEALTH AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THIS CONVERSATION IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE IT'S NOT BEING
HAD IN A GLOBAL PANDEMIC CAN BE
HARD TO FOCUS ON ANYTHING BUT TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AS IT
RELATES TO THE PANDEMIC. HOWEVER
WE MUST NOT IGNORE THE IMPACTS
ON THE DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
FOR WOMEN AND BIRTHING PEOPLE
AND BABIES WHO ARE JOINING OUR
WORLD THE FORM THE BEDROCK OF
OUR FUTURE. IN FACT WE'RE HERE
BECAUSE WE WANT TO UP WITH THESE
ISSUES WE WANT UNDERSTAND THEM
WE WANT TO PRIORITIZE THEM AND
WE WANT TO WORK TOGETHER AS A
LEGISLATURE TO RESOLVE THEM. SO
TODAY WE WILL TRY TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND
WE'LL DO OUR BEST BUT IT WILL
ONLY BEGINNING OF THIS
CONVERSATION. SO I AM EXCITED TO
START THE CONVERSATION AND I
HOPE TO FIND SOME ANSWERS IN THE
HOURS AHEAD. SO LET'S GET THIS
STARTED BUT FIRST BEFORE WE DO
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA
FOR HER OPENING REMARKS. THANK
YOU CHAIR BARRICADE HAN AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE
FORESIGHT. AT TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH AT THE BEGINNING OF
YOUR TENURE IN THE LEGISLATURE
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH- AND FOR THE
INVITATION TO BE ABLE TO JOIN.
AS A NEW MEMBER OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. AS A WOMAN OF COLOR
AS A BLACK LATINA AND AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR MY DISTRICT
OAKLAND ALAMEDA AND SAN LEANDRO-
AND CERTAINLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE RECOGNIZE
THE CRITICAL JUNCTURE THAT WE
ARE AT- AS WE- EXPLORE. THE
NECESSITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
ESSENTIALLY BE IN MANY WAYS AT
THE STATE AND THE LAST STAND FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM. IN THIS
COUNTRY- IS INCREDIBLY POIGNANT
IN THIS MOMENT RIGHT NOW AS WE
FACE DOWN THE PANDEMIC. TO
RECOGNIZE THE WAYS IN WHICH OUR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH FOR WOMEN
AND BIRTHING PEOPLE CONTINUES TO
BE SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
STRIVE FOR. AND I AM SO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
TOGETHER AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO EXPLORE WHAT ELSE WE NEED TO
PUT IN PLACE TO ENSURE. THAT WE
CAN HAVE THE IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC MEDICATED. AS YOU
MENTIONED AT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY ON THE RISE
THE SITUATION THAT WE'VE HAD TO
STRUGGLE WITH PARTICULARLY. IN
OUR COMMUNITIES- ARE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
ACCESSIBLE HEALTH CARE. FOR
WOMEN IN BIRTHING PEOPLE
CONTINUES TO BE OF GRAVE
CONCERN. FOR US ALL AND I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THIS
COMMITTEE AS WE CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE AT THESE ISSUES THE
INTERSECTION ALITY AND THE
DIFFERENTIAL IMPACTS THAT THIS-
MOMENTS OF THE PANDEMIC AT THIS
MOMENT OF. NEEDING TO FIGHT FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE HAS HAD ON
BLACK WOMEN LATINO WOMEN AND-
AND PROTECT PEOPLE AND THAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AS A
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL WHICH WILL
COVER DELAYED CARE DURING
COVERED WE HAVE THREE INCREDIBLE
PANELISTS WE HAVE DOCTOR JOYCE
SU TASIA WHO IS AN OBGYN
PHYSICIAN SPECIALIST WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH SERVICES WE HAVE DR
DAMIAN LA SHED DIRECTOR WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH FOR QUEST
DIAGNOSTICS WHO WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A REAL. INSIGHT INTO-
WHAT THE TESTING HAS SHOWN US
IT'S HAPPENING TO WOMEN BREAKING
PEOPLE THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND
ROSE AFRAID DIRECTOR OF QUALITY
MANAGEMENT AND NURSING FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD MAR MONTE. SO
I WENT IN BY EACH OF YOU TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT WHAT YOU
HAVE SEEN THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC
AND HOW IT RELATES TO DELAYED
CARE WE'LL START WITH YOU
DOCTOR. TO TEAR JEFF. THANK GOD
AFTER HEARING- MY NAME IS TRACY
PAGE- I AM LIKE I AS AS YOU SAID
IN THE- AFTER. SPECIALIST AN
OBSTETRICS AND GYNECOLOGY THE
ONLY DEPARTMENT- HEALTH
SERVICES. AND I DID WANT TO
START BY SAYING THAT I THINK
THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN-
REALLY CHALLENGING FOR A
PARTICULAR STOCK STARTED
PATIENTS ARE PRIMARILY OUR
MEDICAL PATIENTS OF WHICH ABOUT
80% OF MY PATIENT POPULATION
MEDICAL PATIENTS AND- THEIR
MAJOR TEND TO BE EITHER-
UNINSURED OR JUST KIND OF. A
SMATTERING OF OTHER PUBLIC
INSURANCE SAYS- AND WE FOUND
THAT THERE ARE PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL DELAYS. IN CARE THAT
OUR PATIENTS ARE EXPERIENCING-
JUST FROM THE SHEER VOLUME OF.
OUR OUR PATIENTS HAVE SORT OF
SORT OF OVERWHELMED BECAUSE-
ANYWAY. I'M SORRY SOMETHING THAT
WE I THINK I GOING TO BE JUST L.
BUT I MEAN I DO FIND THAT MUST
REGULATIONS HAVE BEEN ADDED. I
HAVE HAD SOME CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF. SEEKING CARE AND BEING
ABLE TO- TO- HAVE APPROPRIATE
CARE FOR- YOU KNOW WOMEN'S
HEALTH ISSUES AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH ISSUES. THANK YOU THANK
YOU DR CITIES THAT I'M DOCTOR
ALYSIA INTRODUCE YOURSELF. OKAY
I'M DOCTOR NAME ALEISHA FROM A
QUEST DIAGNOSTICS AND- I HAVE A
PRISON TATIAN MADAM CHAIR- I
THINK THAT I NEED TO YOU NEED TO
STUDY SEND ME VIA. THE SHARE
BUTTON IS THAT THE WAY IT WORKS
. YES ALL RIGHT SO I HAVE A VERY
GO HANG OUT. HEY LET'S SEE WHICH
ONE OF THESE WONDERFUL
PRESENTATIONS THAT I CAN PULL UP
HERE. SEE HERE SYSTEM ONE. OKAY
LOOK AT THAT MY CHILDREN WOULD
BE SO PROUD OF ME OKAY SO- GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN I'M BACK TO
BEING ALEISHA I'M A BOARD
CERTIFIED OBGYN WHO NOW SERVES
AS THE SENIOR MEDICAL DIRECTOR
FOR WOMEN'S HEALTH AND- ADVANCED
DIAGNOSTICS THE QUEST- IN
INTERESTING PLACE EXHORTATION
IMPRESSED WITH IT TO BE RIGHT
NOW AFTER HAVING HAD A LONG
CAREER IN OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY AND NOW MOVES OVER
THE- DIAGNOSTIC SIDE IS THAT WE-
TAKE CARE. ABOUT YOUR 50% OF THE
POSITION LAP LABORATORIES- IN
THE UNITED STATES NOW WE PROVIDE
ALL THOSE TESTS AND ALSO ABOUT
ONE IN THREE ADULT AMERICANS
COME THROUGH OUR LABS EVERY
EVERY YEAR- SO IN THIS
INCREDIBLE ORGANIZATION WITH AN
INCREDIBLE FOOTPRINT INCREDIBLE
COMMITMENT TO WOMEN'S HEALTH AND
I WANNA MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR AND
ALSO. TO INEQUITIES IN HEALTH-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES WITH ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY PATIENTS CENTERS.
AND OUR FOCUS IS REALLY ON
PREVENTIVE CARE EARLY DIAGNOSIS
MANAGEMENT OF CHRONIC CARE AND
BEING YOU KNOW AS IT REALLY
PARTNERS WITH YOU OUR HEALTH
SYSTEM COLLEAGUES AND OUR-
COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT THE
THROUGHOUT THE STATES AND REALLY
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT I'M GOING TO BE FOCUSING
AYE ABOUT SEVEN SLIDES HERE AND
I REALIZE I HAVE FIVE MINUTES
ALL RUSHED THROUGH AS MUCH AS I
CAN I WILL I'M NOT GONNA TALK
ABOUT CHLAMYDIA GONORRHEA
PRACTICAL GONORRHEA I AM THE
FOCUS PRIMARILY ON CHLAMYDIA.
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE SEE
ALL THE TIME- I SEE THAT SHE IS
SMILING BECAUSE THIS IS YOUR
SHE'S PROBABLY JUST HAD OUR
BOARDS BECAUSE I CAN SEE THAT
YOU'RE NOT LONG OUT OF YOUR
RESIDENCY. BUT THIS IS WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT TALK ABOUT
CHLAMYDIA- THIS IS NOT AN
ABSTRACTION YOU SEE THIS ALL THE
TIME THE WOMAN HAS UP A PILLOW
SHE'S HOLDING APOLLO BECAUSE
SHE'S IN PAIN AND THE REASON
SHE'S IN PAIN IS BECAUSE SHE HAS
OCCASIONS SHE HAS IN FACT
INFORMATION OR PELVISTHAT'S
CAUSED BY SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTION. THAT EITHER WAS ON
DIAGNOSED YOU KNOW DIAGNOSE TO
NOT TREATED CORRECTLY SHE DIDN'T
HAVE FOLLOW UP IN THIS LEADS TO
INFERTILITY. CHRONIC PELVIC PAIN
X. BUT PREGNANCY SOME. PRETERM
BIRTH IN MAY WE'RE TALK ABOUT
THE PRIME DAY. URETHRITIS
INHABITED. NOW OKAY GREAT CHAU
ME THE DATA- THE IS WHAT IT
FOCUS ON THE STATE OF. BUT I'M
GONNA FOR IT IN A LARGER. FOR
MAY. LIMITING GUN. THE NEW JUST
KEEP GOING UP THIS IS TWO
THOUSAND BECAUSE- NINETEEN AND
MAY GIVE YOU SOME FACTS ON THIS
. GONORRHEA THE SAME THING IT'S
INTERESTING THAT IT'S FLIPPED.
IN BETWEEN MEN AND WOMEN
STARTING AROUND TWENTY THIRTEEN.
NOW LISTS THIS IS THE THAT THE
FACT SHEET IF YOU WELL SOMEBODY
A FAX ABOUT TWO MILLION. CASES
OF CHLAMYDIA WERE REPORTED IS
REPORTABLE DISEASE. THE CDC IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWO MILLION
CASES. OVERALL RATE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO THE HIGHEST RATES AND
THIS IS WHAT BREAKS YOUR HEART.
AS WELL ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG
ADULTS. A TWO THIRDS 61% WERE
AMONG PERSONS AGED FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR. AND SO YOU LOOK AT
THE OVERALL RATE UP HERE AT FIVE
FIFTY TWO YOU LOOK AT THE
ADOLESCENT RIGHT EXCUSE ME. FOR
BASICALLY FOUR THOUSAND PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT YOU SAY
WHERE DOES CALIFORNIA SAID BUT
THAT. CALIFORNIA IS RANKED
NUMBER FIFTEEN. IN THE COUNTRY-
YOUR CASE RATE THIS IS ROB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT OR SIX HUNDRED
SLIGHTLY ABOVE THIS CASE RIGHT.
WHICH IS ABOUT. TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND ROUND NUMBERS
AND- AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
GONNA SEE THIS IN A MINUTE
YOU'RE KIND OF THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT THIS IS
HAVING ON DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
SO. DOES THE COMPANY OR FAX TWO
MILLION. AND IMPACTING YOU KNOW
THAT ONE OUT OF THE ADOLESCENTS
AND THIS IS THE SIDE THAT I.
REALLY WANT YOU TO. IN BED IN
YOUR MAY. IS THAT YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE THANK FOR A- AND EUROPE
AND THE- FIFTEEN. AND ACTUALLY.
YOU SEE THE YOU KNOW THREE THE-
FIFTEEN AND I- YOU KNOW FOR THE
- ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND THIS
IS WHAT'S CAUSING THE PAIN THE
INFERTILITY THE PRETERM BIRTH.
AND WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS. NOW I CAN GO OVER
CHLAMYDIA IT'S ABOUT A QUARTER
OF WHAT YOU SEE WITH- GOT. A
STUDENT WITH A LOT OF FOCUS ON
GONORRHEA SPETTACOLO WHAT YOU
SEE WITH CHLAMYDIA. YOU CA 92%
INCREASE MOSTLY AMONG MEN- AND
THEN THIS IS THE- THE GIRLS ARE
GONNA REYES FACTS BUT I A FULL.
YOUR BACK TO THIS ONE. AND I
KNOW THIS IS A YEAR I DON'T SAY
THIS IS BUSY BECAUSE OF MY
PROFESSORS IN MED SCHOOL SAID
THAT. YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW I JUST
GO TO SLEEP WAS BUSY OF ME IS
NOT IMPORTANT I WANT TO BREAK
THIS DOWN FOR YOU SIR AT THE
BOTTOM WHAT YOU SEE. THE AND
PANDEMIC AFFECTING Q. ONE Q. TWO
Q. THREE Q. FOUR THE BLUE BARS
IN THE BACK. OUR WHAT WE SAW
DURING A NORMAL YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN AND YOU ALWAYS SEE A
FALL OFFERED TESTING VOLUMES AS
WE HAVE OVER HERE. AROUND
THANKSGIVING AND AROUND THE
HOLIDAY TIME. BUT WHAT WE SEE
YOU KNOW AGAIN WHEN THE PANDEMIC
COMES AROUND. IS THAT IT JUST
CREATORS AND PEOPLE THESE ARE
TEST PINES WE STOP GETTING WOMEN
TESTED WOMEN STOP COULDN'T GO TO
CLINICS. THE CLINICS WERE SHUT
DOWN WE WERE DOING TESTING FOR
CHLAMYDIA AND GONORRHEA SO AND
INTERESTINGLY YOU SEE AN
INCREASE HERE IN THE OVERALL
RATE I THINK YOU SEE THAT. ARE
IN THE PERCENTAGE POSITIVITY BUT
THAT'S BECAUSE THE WOMEN WHO HAD
IT NEEDED TO GO GET TESTED. SO
WE'RE MISSING ALL OF THESE WOMEN
THIS IS THE IMPACT THESE ARE
THESE WOMEN HAVE BEEN LOST TO
CARE. AND LAW AND SO THE LOS
SECURE LOS TO FOLLOW UP AND
THEY'RE GONNA END UP POSSIBLY
WITH THAT MOLDERING INFECTION
SO OF THE TEST VOLUME NUMBERS.
WE ALWAYS SIT AROUND BASICALLY
THREE AFTER 4% POSITIVITY- BUT
IF WE'RE NOT TESTING THE PEOPLE
WERE NOT SEEN THEM AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BE SHOWING UP. IN THE
WITH THE WITH THE PROBLEMS-
COMMENSURATE WITH UNDIAGNOSED
CHLAMYDIA INFECTION- THE SAME
THING YOU'RE GONNA SEE IT WITH
GONORRHEA THEY THEY REALLY MATCH
EACH OTHER YOU SEE THE PANDEMIC
A FACT- I DON'T REALLY WANT IT
YOU KNOW YOU SEE AN UPTICK IN-
IN GONORRHEA WHICH IS ACTUALLY
PRETTY INTERESTING- AND THAT'S-
YOUR WORK. I THINK THAT THAT'S
YOU KNOW FROM THE MSM
POPULATION. IN ANY EVENT WHAT
WE'RE SEEING HERE AND I WANT TO
GO BACK IS. UNDIAGNOSED
UNTREATED YOU KNOW AND THESE
PEOPLE ARE MESSED. M. LAST NIGHT
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU. IS THE
IMPACT THIS IS THE- SLIDE. THE
WHITE AREA. DOWN HERE I'M I'M
NOT FROM WITH THE STATE OF. I
MEAN HE'S CO PERSON SO I PUT THE
STATE OF. MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
WHO. DON'T KNOW WHERE CAL. IS
BUT USE. WHAT WE UP HERE IS YOU
SEE THE LARGEST DIG. IN THESE Y.
AREAS. OVER HERE IN THE LARGEST
. IN TESTING IN THE DARK BLUE
AREAS. AND I WOULD VENTURE TO
SAY THAT THESE ARE THE AREAS
THAT ARE MOST IN NEED. THAT ARE
MOST UNDERSERVED THAT HAVE THE
POOREST ACCESS TO CARE. AND IF
WE DON'T ADDRESS THIS
COLLECTIVELY WE'RE GONNA BE.
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE.
DOWNLINE BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY-
YOU'RE GONNA BE HURTING WOMEN
REALLY HURTING LIMON YOU'RE
GONNA BE HURTING BABIES. SO MY
CLOSING POINTS ARE PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD. SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS ARE
RISING. THEY CONTINUE TO RISE.
IF LEFT UNDIAGNOSED THESE STI
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
IF UNDIAGNOSED AND UNTREATED
IMPACT THE LIVES OF BABIES-
MATURITY ADOLESCENTS.
INFERTILITY AND ADULTS PUBLIC
PAIN INFERTILITY ECTOPIC.
PREGNANCY THE CODEPENDENT.
RESULTED IN THE DECREASE BE
CREATIVE MATTEL. J. THIS. EXIST
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT HAD ON.
WE AS HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HEALTHCARE
POLICY MAKERS. SHARE THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES HEAD ON AND I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THAT
BUT WE'RE ALSO IS BLESSED
ORGANIZATION WE'RE COMMITTED TO
HELPING THIS AND ANYTHING THAT
YOU KNOW WE CAN DO OR I CAN DO.
TO HELP YOU ALL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
YOU JUST CALL ME I'M THERE SO
THAT'S MY SHORT PRESENTATION I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
AND- THAT'S ALL I HAVE I'M GONNA
LET YOU WILL TAKE THE TAKE THE
BALL BACK IN AND TAKE I OVER.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU DR
LEISHA THAT WE WILL NOT SHOULD
OVER TO ROSA FRAME FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MAR MONTE TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT SHE'S SEEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. Q. MY NAME IS ROSE
FREIGHT AND- FAMILY NURSE. OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD MAR MONTE. I
WORKED WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
FOR SIXTEEN YEARS. AND MOST
RECENTLY JOINED OUR MEDICAL
MANAGEMENT TEAM IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS DIRECTOR OF QUALITY
MANAGEMENT AND NURSING. DURING
THE PANDEMIC LIKE MANY OF US AS
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
MY QUALITY MANAGEMENT PARTY'S
QUICKLY SHIFTED FROM AGENDA
ITEMS LIKE ROUTINE HEALTH
SERVICES- INSURING FOR MEETING
INTERNAL QUALITY METRICS- SET
FORTH. INTERNALLY AND THROUGH BY
THE COUNTY STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVELS. THIS QUICKLY SHIFTED TO
KEEPING OUR STAFF AND PATIENT
SAFETY IN THE MIDST OF PANDEMIC
AND OUR DOORS OPEN TO CONTINUE
CLINICAL SERVICES BUT THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEEDED US. AT
MY MUNCIE LAUNCHED INTO ACTION
TO PROVIDE VERY QUICKLY COBIT
NINETEEN TESTING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WE ARE IN. I
DID STAFF COULD NINETEEN. THIS
INCLUDED DRIVING THROUGH OUR
AFFILIATE IF AND YOU AREN'T
AWARE OF SOME OF YOUR TO WHERE
WE EXPAND FROM AT MY MUNCIE
SPANS A VAST REGION OVER BASS
REGION FROM RENO NEVADA ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO BAKERSFIELD. SO THAT
WE WERE SUCCESSFULLY. WE'VE
SUCCESSFULLY PROVIDED ABOUT
SIXTEEN THOUSAND COBIT NINETEEN
TESTS OVER THREE HUNDRED
VACCINES TO STAFF AND MOST
RECENTLY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
POSTERS. I'M PROUD TO BE A PART
OF A COMMUNITY HEALTH PARTNER
SOMEONE CONSIDER EVEN A LEADER
IN PROVIDING HEALTH CARE AND
EDUCATION IN BY EXPANDING RIGHTS
AND ACCESS FOR COMMUNITIES. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO SHARING MORE
OF HOW THE KOBE NINETEEN IMPACT
HAS AND CONTINUES TO DIRECTLY
IMPACT OUR PATIENTS AND HOW WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS SO THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO JOIN YOUR HOUSE. THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH FOR THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS I GUESS I WOULD
START BY ASKING- BOTH ABBAS FRAY
AND DOCTORS CITYJET. AND WHAT
INCREASE NEEDS HAVE YOU SEEN
DURING KOBE- ARE THERE. WHAT ARE
WE SEEING WITH PREGNANT PEOPLE
PREGNANCY COMPLICATIONS WHAT HAS
CHANGED IN TERMS OF WHAT
PATIENTS ARE APPEARING IN YOUR
CLINICS WITH. THAT RESEARCHERS
ARE YOU WANNA TAKE THAT FIRST.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
PERSONALLY FOUND IN MY PRACTICES
THAT AND BECAUSE OF THE- THERE'S
BEEN ACTUALLY THE STATE HOME
ORDERS AND YOU KNOW KIND OF AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC WE
WERE VERY CAUTIOUS IN TERMS OF.
HAVING PATIENTS PHYSICALLY
PRESENT TO OUR CLINICS FOR CARE-
AND WE DID FIND THAT A LOT OF- I
KNOW PEOPLE HAVE CHOSEN TO.
DELAY SEEKING CARE FOR THEIR
PREGNANCIES SO- LATE ENTRY TO
CARE HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES THAT WE'VE SEEN IN AND
ARE PREGNANT AND READING
POPULATION- BECAUSE PEOPLE
WAITING. TO SEE CARE UNTIL LATER
ON IN THEIR PREGNANCY- THERE IS-
YOUR HUSBAND A TREND TOWARDS. IN
THE HIGHER ACUITY A PREGNANCY AT
TIME OF PRESENTATION. BECAUSE
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS- A PREGNANT
PERSON WELL AS A PRE EXISTING
CONDITION LIKE DIABETES OR
HYPERTENSION HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE- I FOR EXAMPLE HAD A
PATIENT WHO IS A PRETTY- BRITTLE
DIABETIC SHE HAS VERY DIFFICULT
TO CONTROL BLOOD SUGARS. AND
BECAUSE. SHE BECAME PREGNANT SHE
THOUGHT. I'M THAT ALL OF
DIABETES NOT ARE GOING TO BE
SAFE AND- SO SHE'S. TAKING ALL
OF THEM AND DUE TO THE- AND THEN
DIDN'T PRESENT TO CARE BECAUSE
YOU'RE AFRAID- ABOUT- BEING
EXPOSED TO COALBED DIDN'T STEEP
KAREN TOLD. WELL AFTER- SO
PROBABLY ACCEPT TWENTY SOMETHING
WEEKS- I'VE JUST STATION. SO FOR
HER BY THE TIME SHE GOT TO US WE
HAD TO SEND HER TO THE HOSPITAL
TO CONTROL HER BLOOD SUGARS
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO. WILDLY OUT
OF CONTROL- AND SO OBVIOUSLY
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT. THIS
PARTICULAR PATIENT IMPACT NOT
ONLY HER AND HER FUTURE HEALTH
BUT ALSO THE HEALTH OF HER AND
HER BABY. WHO ALLEN IT'S PAST%
THE POINT WHERE ALL OF ITS
ORGANS ARE DEVELOPING- AND WE DO
KNOW THAT I'M CONTROL DIABETES
AS IMPACTS IN TERMS OF- IN
DEVELOPMENT OF THE BRAIN-
DEVELOPMENT OF THE HEART SO
BABIES CAN HAVE. ANOMALIES DUE
TO UNCONTROLLED DIABETES SO A
LOT OF A LOT OF ISSUES LIKE THAT
ARE COMING UP WHERE WHERE ON
PATIENTS ARE DECIDING NOT TO
PRESENT UNTIL QUITE LATE- AND-
ITS RESULTING. PRETTY MAJOR
COMPANY. NC'S THANK YOU FOR
THAT- THIS RADIO AT ANYTHING TO
IT YOU'RE SEEING A PLAN PARA
MOMENTOUS. SO ONE OF THE FEW
SILVER LINING AND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS CAUSED BY COULD BE
NINETEEN WAS THE ACCELERATION OF
OUR TELEHEALTH SERVICES ACROSS
ALL OF OUR HEALTH CENTERS. AT WE
WERE ABLE TO MAKE THIS WITH
TRANSITION AND GET UP AND
RUNNING AND ABOUT THREE WEEKS
SHIFTING YOU KNOW FROM IN PERSON
TO TELEHEALTH WAS INITIALLY
CHALLENGING BUT MOST OF OUR
PATIENTS RECENTLY HEARD PRIME.
AND APPRECIATED THIS OPTION AND
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF IT BECAUSE IT
WAS SAFE AND IT WAS CONVENIENT.
THIS YOU KNOW OPEN ACCESS TO
THOSE PATIENTS WHO WERE NOW HOME
WITH THEIR SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
IN DISTANCE LEARNING AND THIS
OPEN ACCESS TO THOSE PATIENTS
WHOSE STILL HAD TO GO TO WORK
EVERY DAY AND NEEDED TO DO THESE
VISITS ON THEIR LUNCH BREAKS.
AND IT'S JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF
HOW MANY YOU KNOW RELIED ON
THESE TELEHEALTH VISITS DURING
THE PANDEMIC 4260% OF OUR VISITS
WERE COMPLETED USING TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. AND. WEEK QUICK EIGHT.
FOUND OUT THAT MANY OF OUR
VISITS BE TELEPATHIC FAMILY
MEDICINE. JENNER FOR MAKING AND
HARMAN THERAPY. PRACTICE ITS
INFECTION SCREENINGS
PRESCRIPTION BASED BIRTH CONTROL
EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION. WE WERE
AND- ALSO TO LEVERAGE TELEHEALTH
FOR EVEN TRIAGING PATIENTS TO
SEE IF THEY ACTUALLY NEED TO
COME INTO THE HEALTH CENTER SO.
BECAUSE OF THIS WE WERE ABLE TO
KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN AND SERVICES
GOING. AND WE ALSO LOOKED AT
CURBSIDE PICKUPS FOR BIRTH
CONTROL AND YOU KNOW THAT WAS AN
OPTION BELIEVE WE LAUNCHED
PRETTY QUICKLY- OUR FAMILY
MEDICINE SITES USE POINT OF CARE
TESTING. AND COPING NINETEEN
TEST COLLECTION VIA CURBSIDE AND
FORTUNATELY WE DIDN'T SEE MUCH
OF A DELAY IN OUR SERVICES WERE
AND ARE PUSHING CARE SERVICES
DURING THE PANDEMIC. OBTAINING
PREGNANCY OPTIONS IN COUNSELING
IS CONSIDERED. TIME SENSITIVE
SERVICE AND WITH THIS WE KNEW WE
HAD TO ACT QUICKLY TO MEET OUR
PATIENTS ABORTION CARE NEEDS AND
ENABLING OUR CLINICIANS REFER TO
BURKE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THIS SERVICE. AND WE LEARNED A
LOT ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THESE
VISITS MORE EFFICIENT AND EASIER
FOR OUR PATIENTS TO ACCESS
TELEHEALTH IS BEEN. ESSENTIAL TO
KEEP IS GOING. THANK YOU ALL
TURN OVER TEMAS BONTA FOR. THANK
YOU I A QUESTION DIRECTED I
THINK- PRIMARILY TO MISS FREY-
EIGHT CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE IF
YOU WERE TAKEN PROJECT THE NEEDS
THAT YOU HAVE IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL ACCESS TO CARE MOVING
FORWARD COVERT WE'RE NOT DONE
WITH CO VIDEO AT- AND- AND SO WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASED ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
USE METHODS LIKE TELEHEALTH AS-
A MEANS TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
BUT IT JUST TO GIVE US A SENSE
OF WHAT ELSE WE NEED. MOVING
FORWARD FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. YES SO AND YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR TELEHEALTH BY VIDEO
AND PHONE VISITS WITH
APPROPRIATE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
IS. ESSENTIAL TO CONTINUE OUR
SERVICES. WE FOUND THAT WE
NEEDED TO INCREASE AT WE FOUND
THAT WE HAD AN INCREASE IN NEED
FOR TELEHEALTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. AND UNFORTUNATELY
THERE IS AT THIS TIME LACK OF
STATE FUNDING FOR THIS SPECIFIC
TYPE OF SERVICE- SYPHILIS
SCREENING IS. CRITICAL TO THE
FIGHT IF THAT YOU KNOW FOR THE
SIDE OF THE FIGHT FOR THAT
SIPPLE'S EPIDEMIC- AND WE NEED
TO FIND A WAY TO. I'D SURPLUS
TESTING AND TREATMENT- I'M
FUNDING INNOVATION IDEAS AT
LARGE BY IN PLACES LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MAR MONTE IS. IS
ESSENTIALLY THE ANSWER TO AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN GENERAL FUNDING
THAT FOCUSES ON IMPORTANCE OF
STI TESTING AND PILOTING TESTING
METHODS THAT BETTER MEET THE
PUBLIC NEEDS EXAMPLES COULD BE
LIKE RAPID IN CLINIC TESTING. AT
HOME TESTING TO INCLUDE PATIENTS
SELF COLLECTION METHODS- AND
THEN THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY
WOULD BE YOU KNOW THIS THERE'S
THIS DISCOURSE WITH VACCINE
FUNDING OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS-
WE PROVIDE SEVERAL VACCINES IN
OUR HEALTH CENTERS BUT THERE'S
ACTUALLY NOT FUNDING FOR US FOR.
TAXIS WHICH IS EACH PEAVEY.
VACCINE AT THIS TIME AND JUST
WRITE YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE WHERE
INCREASE FUNDING AND LARGELY IN
SETTINGS. WOULD HAVE A GREAT
IMPACT. THANK YOU. I WOULD
ACTUALLY ADAM LIVED HER DOCTORS
WHO TASIA REFLECT ON THAT AS IT
RELATES TO THE DELAYS YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT SORT OF WHAT WE
CAN DO TO ENSURE THAT- BURNING
PEOPLE AND WOMEN WHO NEED OTHER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE ARE
SHOWING UP- EARLIER. NO ACTUALLY
I AGREE WITH MISS FREY HONEST ON
TOP WE'VE ALSO EXPANDED OUR
TELEHEALTH EARNED ABILITIES AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE A LOT
OF FUN IT IS IT'S ACTUALLY
EXPANDING OUT TO DO
VIDEOCASSETTES AS WELL- AND BE
ABLE TO BE APPROPRIATELY
REIMBURSED FOR THOSE VISITS IS
KIND OF CHALLENGING I THINK
THOSE VISITS- AREN'T. AT THE WE
DON'T AT IN TERMS OF OUR
REIMBURSEMENT IS JUST THERE'S
SEVERAL OF THOSE THAT THAT MAKE
UP LIKE A SINGLE IN PERSON VISIT
FOR EXAMPLE- SO I THINK HAVING
SOME ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO BE
ABLE TO. INCREASED ONE OF THE
MAJOR ISSUES WITH MEDIC HOW IS
THAT THERE AREN'T A LOT OF
PROVIDERS IN THAT SYSTEM MANY
PEOPLE CHOOSE MANY PHYSICIANS
MANY- CLINICIANS CHOOSE NOT TO
TAKE MEDIC- AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THE POOR REIMBURSEMENT
RATE. AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT- N. AS IN THE PANDEMIC
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR JOBS THEY LOSE
THEIR ABILITY TO BECOME
INSURANCE A STATE TRANSITION TO
PUBLIC INSURANCE- AND- THE
PUBLIC INSURANCE SYSTEM IS
COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED BY SUCH A
LARGE VOLUME OF PEOPLE AND NOT
ENOUGH. PROVIDERS TO PRIME BY
CARE FOR THOSE PEOPLE- SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT WE SORT OF THIS
LIKE. DOUBT YOU KNOW TRICKLE A
FACT WHERE NOW WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PROVIDERS BECAUSE NO
PROVIDERS AREN'T BEING
REIMBURSED APPROPRIATELY FOR THE
KIND OF CARE- AND THEN WE HAVE
JUST THIS HUGE SORT OF BACKLOG
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE. UNABLE TO GET
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED WITHIN A
TIMELY MANNER. AND SO IT JUST TO
STIR BACK THAT INCREASE OUR
REMEMBER RATES FOR VERY AT FOR
THE THAT MAKE IT. AT CARE MORE
ACCESSIBLE WOULD BE GREAT. YEAH
I THINK THAT MAKES SENSE AND ONE
OF THE BENEFITS OF TELEHEALTH IS
THAT WHERE WE HAVE- DESERT'S OF
MEDI CAL PROVIDERS OR PROVIDERS
GENERALLY W CAN PROVIDE. CARE
AT A. DISTANCE WHICH IS VERY
NICE BECAUSE I THINK AS SHOWN
AND DR. ALICIA ALICIA IS MAP
RIGHT WE KNOW WE HAVE DOZENS OF
KAREN CALIFORNIA- AND AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE LESS PROVIDERS
BUT- WE ARE SHORT MEDICAL
PROVIDERS EVERYWHERE SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO WHAT WE CAN
TO IMPROVE THAT SITUATION. AS WE
INCREASE ACCESS TO MEDICARE
WHICH WE DID THIS YEAR. NEED TO
MAKE SURE WERE. INCREASING THE
PROVIDERS OTHERWISE WE'RE GONNA
OVERWHELM YOU ANY OTHER.
INCREDIBLE FIGHTERS OUT THERE AT
BUT ON TOP OF THAT RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY HEARING A LOT
ABOUT AND- STAFFING SHORTAGES.
AT ALL LEVELS OF EMPLOYMENT. I'M
AND I'M WONDERING HOW THAT HAS.
AFFECTED YOUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
CARE ON TOP OF THE SHORTAGE YOU
ALREADY MENTIONED- DO YOU WANT
TO. TAKE THAT FIRST STEP
DECISIONS. SURE AND WE HAVE HAD
SOME PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL STAFFING
SHORTAGES AS YOU MENTIONED WHAT
THE PHENOMENON THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW AS YOU PROBABLY HEARD
IN THE NEWS IS BAD- IN AREAS
THAT ARE HARDEST HIT BY COALBED.
THERE ARE OFFERING HUGE
INCENTIVES FOR NURSES TO TRAVEL
NURSES TO GO THEIR WORK FOR
SHORT PERIODS OF TIME GET PAID
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF MONEY-
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY PULLING AWAY
FROM OUR OUR- STAFF NURSES- AT
MOST OF OUR HOSPITALS. SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS WE HAVE MAJOR
STAFFING SHORTAGES ON OUR LABOR
AND DELIVERY FLOOR OPERATING
ROOMS AND WE ARE HUGELY LIMITING
THE AMOUNT OF CARE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR MEDICAL PATIENTS-
CURRENTLY WE'RE LIMITED TO THAT
WE HAVE THIS. AT JUST TO GIVE
SOME BACKGROUND SO SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENS- DURING THE
PANDEMIC WAS THAT- NON ESSENTIAL
SURGERIES NON EMERGENT SURGERIES
BOARD THE LATEST OF THINGS THAT
WERE DEEMED ELECTIVE SURGERIES-
FOR EXAMPLE- AS- THE WOMEN WHO
HAS- REALLY REALLY HEAVY
MENSTRUAL BLEEDING. I'M TO THE
POINT WHERE SHE BECOMES ANEMIC
NEEDS MULTIPLE BLOOD
TRANSFUSIONS- BUT YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT LIFE THREATENING- AND
OVERALL SHE'S STABLE SHE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL AFTER YOU
KNOW. THINGS HAVE BOOSTED UP
WITH A PANDEMIC TO BILL TO GET
HER SURGERY FORTUNATELY
UNFORTUNATELY SHE'S NOT THE ONLY
ONE WHO HAD THAT ISSUE THERE ARE
JUST SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE THAT
HAD THAT ISSUES OUR BACKLOG AS-
YOU KNOW- NOT EMERGENT CASE
SAYS. HAS JUST EXPANDED- AND NOW
WE ARE FURTHER CONTACTED BY THIS
LACK OF ALL OUR STAFF. AND
THAT'S KIND OF CONTRACT IN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT WERE ABLE TO
OPERATE SO FOR EXAMPLE MY
OPERATING ROOM CAN ONLY FUNCTION
FROM SEVEN IN THE MORNING AND
TELL- THREE IN THE AFTERNOON
WHEN NORMALLY WE CAN GO BEYOND
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S A SHIFT
CHANGE AND THEN. AT THREE PM WE
HAVE TO CUT DOWN TO ONLY THREE
OPERATING ROOMS FOR THE ENTIRE
HOSPITAL SO. IT BECOMES
CHALLENGING THAT WAY BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOT ONLY THIS HUGE BACKLOG
BUT THEN ON OUR SIDE OF THINGS
WHERE FURTHER CONTRACTED AND HOW
MUCH WE'RE ABLE TO GIVE BECAUSE
WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE. TO PROVIDE THAT CARE-
AND SIMILARLY A LABOR AND
DELIVERY SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
THREE NURSES FOR THE ENTIRE
FLOOR WHICH IS. YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES UNSAFE SO WE DO THE
BEST WE CAN WITH THE LIMITED
RESOURCES WE HAVE BUT THE
PANDEMIC IS POLLING STAFF- AWAY
FROM. HERE IN. PLACES ARE MORE
CARDS HIT BUT IT ON A- THANK YOU
FOR CONTINUING TO WORK UNDER
WHAT SEEM LIKE INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES-
MISREAD ANYTHING TO ADD ON THE
STAFFING SHORTAGE QUESTION- JUST
THAT LIKE MANY HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS YOU KNOW. A CLINICIAN
SH STAFFING SHORTAGE YOU TO CODE
NINETEEN WAS EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING FOR US- AND HOW DOES
THEIR CLINICIANS AND HEALTH
CENTER STAFF FOR MISSION DRIVEN
AND COMMITTING TO PROVIDING THE
ESSENTIAL CARE TO PATIENTS- BUT
MUCH LIKE- IT. WAS STATED BEFORE
IT HITS. HAVE AN IMPACT ON
ACCESSIBILITY. THANK YOU I'M
ACTUALLY A TURNED TO DR LISA
WITH A QUESTION ABOUT THAT
CANCER SCREENINGS AND YOU KNOW
WE HEARD FROM YOU ABOUT STI'S
BUT I'M CURIOUS WHAT YOU'VE SEEN
IN THE AREA OF CANCER SCREENINGS
AND WHETHER WE'RE SEEING THAT
SAME DAY IF YOU SHOWED US FOR
STI TESTING AS IT RELATES TO
WHAT ARE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY LIFE
THREATENING ILLNESSES. YOUR
MUTED DOCTOR SHOWS THAT OUR
FAULTS. OKAY BUT I'LL ANOTHER
ANOTHER PRESENTATION ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE WE PRESENTED THAT- DATA
IN A JAM UP ARTICLE AND WE SAW
YOU KNOW THE LAY CARE YOU ARE
RESULT IN ADVANCED- PRESENTATION
CANCERS. IN COLORECTAL LUNG
PANCREATIC I MEAN YOU NAME IT
WAS THEIR PATIENTS COULDN'T GET
IN FOR THE SCREENING AND YOU
KNOW SO WHEN THEY'RE NOT GETTING
IN FOR THEIR SCREENING OF A LOT
OF THESE CANCERS THAT ARE GOING
TO GO RAPIDLY GROW RAPIDLY AND
THEY PRESENT AN ADVANCED STAGE
SO THE ANSWER IS YES GO AHEAD OF
SEEKING HAS HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON CANCER SCREENINGS
CANCER DIAGNOSIS AND THE CANCER
DIAGNOSIS THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE WHICH IS THE EARLY
DIAGNOSTICS. OF CANCER- ANY I'D
SAY THAT'S REALLY ACROSS THE
BOARD AND IF I MAY JUST PICK UP
ON WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER- KAREN EXISTENCE I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
MINDSET- THAT WE'VE HAD FOR SUCH
A LONG TIME A MEDIINE WHICH IS
FOCUSED ON DISEASE MANAGEMENT
DISEASE KAREN'S ADVANCED STAGES
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE ALL
TRAINED AS NURSES AND DOCTORS TO
TAKE CARE OF THE END STAGE. AND
YEAH- AS I MOVED THROUGH MY
CAREER- I'M REALIZING NOW THAT
WE NEED TO PICK HIM UP EARLY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE YOU CAN
HAVE A REAL IMPACT NOT ONLY ON
THEIR LIVES THAT CAN IMPACT THE
DOLLARS SO IF I CAN IDENTIFY IT
THIS THIS. WOMAN- THIS PATIENT.
WHAT WE- MINUTES ONE. CORRECT
OKAY. YOU CAN SAY THE- YOU SAVE
A LOT. STATED CHEMOTHER SAVED
HOSPITALS THE GET BACK TO THE
SAME THING HOLDS TRUE. COMEDY I
GOT AND YEAH- YOU MENTIONED AS
FOR THE SIMPLEST YOU KNOW AFTER
THE ACT SAN THING. AND WE TO K.
THEM EARLY. BECAUSE WE KNOW CO
OF IT. AND THIS IS FOR MUCH
ACROSS THE BOARD. THAT IF WE
DON'TCATCH THEM EARLY AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE SYSTEMS IN PLACE
TO IDENTIFY THEM. THEN THEY SHOW
UP LATE AND THEY SHOW UP LATE.
AS- THAT'S TO DIE HE SAID IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM WITH UNCONTROLLED
DIVE DIABETES. AND THAT'S WHEN
IT GETS TO BE REALLY EXPENSIVE.
SO THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION
CIRCLING BACK IS YES WE HAVE
SEEN A DROP IN DIAGNOSIS- FOR
DIAGNOSTIC TOOLS AND WE'RE
SEEING THEM SHOWING UP LATE- IN
LATE STAGES OF CANCER. AND
THAT'S ACROSS THE BOARD IN THIS
IS WHAT THIS IS WHERE IT BREAKS
YOUR HEART BECAUSE. YOU KNOW YOU
COULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE. THAT IS
YOUR- IT'S ALTHOUGH ALASKA
FOLLOW UP QUESTION ALONG THE
THEME MY CAR. WHICH IS DO ANY OF
YOU HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR US
FOR HOW WE CAN HELP ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS ARE GETTING THAT
EARLY SCREENING AND EARLY
DETECTION. YOU KNOW I SAW THAT
YOU WENT TO GEORGETOWN AT MADAM
CHAIR AND I WENT TO GEORGETOWN
TO AND YOU KNOW YOU NEVER ASK
YOUR TOP. IN IT YOU HAVE ANY
ADVICE. AND THE ANSWER IS OF
COURSE WE DO- SO I THINK THAT.
FOR ME IT'S CHANGING THE
MINDSET. AND WE NEED TO GET
PEOPLE STARTING TO THINK ABOUT
PREVENTION. I AND WE SAW THAT
HEALTH AND WELLNESS BUT THAT'S A
BIG STEP. I THINK IT'S
PREVENTION EARLY DIAGNOSIS
SCREENING ACCESS AND DOING THE
SIMPLE THINGS REALLY REALLY
WELL. WE GET FOCUSED ON ON THE
HOSPITAL BASED WORKERS THAT SEXY
THAT'S WELL THAT'S SUPER
EXPENSIVE. BUT I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH BY. THAT'S NOT
WHERE YOU MAKE THE BIGGEST
IMPACT CAN MAKE THE BIGGEST
IMPACT AT THE FRONT END. SO
CHANGING OUR MINDSET. FOR
SCREENING FOR HIM WELL WHEN THEY
WON CITIES FOR COLORECTAL
CANCER- GET THE GET THE PATIENTS
BEFORE THE KIDNEYS ARE DESTROYED
BY DIABETES OR OR THEIR EYES ARE
DESTROYED BY DIABETES. GET THEM
BEFORE THEY SHOW UP WITH PELVIC
ABSCESSES BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN DIAGNOSED. AND I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S WE NEED TO SHIFT
THE CONVERSATION. TO A MORE
EFFECTIVE UTILIZATION OF
SCREENING RESOURCES AND THEN.
THE ABILITY. TO FOLLOW THOSE
PATIENTS UP. THE YOU RESPOND.
ALONG WITH LINES AND I THE
REPHAIM FREE FRAME OF ONE CARE
TO DISTANCE AND FOCUSING MORE ON
A PREVENTATIVE CARE IN THAT
DURING THE PANDEMIC AT BECAUSE
OF THE INCREDIBLE JOB LOSSES
THAT MANY EXPERIENCED- I'M SURE
THAT THAT NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
NEEDED TO GET ON TO MEDICARE ALL
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY I
WONDER- AND I THINK THAT DOCTOR
AT. A LATER THIS MIGHT BE A
QUESTION FOR YOU- I WONDER IF TO
THE EXTENT TO WHICH AT THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM AS IT IS SET UP
RIGHT NOW- IT IS ADOPTING ENOUGH
THE FRAMEWORK THAT YOU SUGGESTED
AROUND A FOCUS ON PREVENTIVE
CARE SCREENING AND- AND TESTING
AND WATCH- WHAT IF ANYTHING YOU
MIGHT AT ARE THERE OTHER FOR
DOCTORS TO TASIA OR- A MYSTERY
THAT MIGHT SUGGEST WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON. TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT. MORE TESTING PREVENTATIVE CARE
. THIS IS A SURPRISE. UM I HAD
TO DEFERRED THAT THE FRONT LINE
YOU KNOW PEOPLE AND THEN. FIGURE
OUT LATER IT'S SUPPORT THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW WE HAD CLASS.
WITH YOUR OUR POWER IN
AFFORDABLE CARE INITIATIVES IN
OUR FOCUS ON- YEAH HEALTHEQUITY.
WE CAN. HELP SUPPORT THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING AND I HAVE
SOME IDEAS ON THAT BUT IF I MAY
I THINK IT BE MORE OKAY. I
ALWAYS LIKE TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE
ON THE FRONT LINES IN THERE ON
THE FRONT LINES I'M- YOU KNOW I
DON'T GET UP IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT IN DO. YOU KNOW C.
SECTION. DELIVERIES ON TWENTY
THREE WEEKS SIR YOU KNOW ERROR
OR HAVE TO DEAL WITH A YOU KNOW
A FULL LOAD OF PATIENTS IN THE
CLINIC I'LL ANSWER THAT QUESTION
BUT I THINK THAT. IF IT'S OKAY
WITH YOU I JUST LIKE THE BEER
FROM THE FRONT LAWN. IS THAT
OKAY. YES PLEASE THIS FOR. DE
CITY. THIS RARE YOU WANT TO GO
FIRST SURE AND SO I GUESS TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE IS WE'RE NOT
SEEING THE VOLUME OF TESTING
LIKE DR ALLEGIANT SHOWED EARLIER
IN THE AND- YOU KNOW WHAT IT
DURING A SLIDE SHOW PRESENTATION
AND NATURALLY DELAYED ROUTINE
HEALTH CARE DURING THE PANDEMIC
LEADS TO FEWER SCREENINGS AND
MORE. AND IN HIGHER INFECTION
RATE SO WHEN WE LOOK AT LIKE THE
CDC REPORTS FOR CALIFORNIA AND
THE GRADUAL INCREASE EVERY YEAR
LIKE FOR PRIMARY AND SECONDARY
SYPHILIS BASED UP WILL BE NO.
AND WITH LESS SCREENING VISITS
THIS. IS NOT YOU KNOW THIS IS
LIKELY TO BE THE CASE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY AS WELL AS WE'RE GONNA BE
GETTING MORE TREATMENT. AND MORE
MANAGING AS THE LACK OF CARE
THAT WEREMADE WERE SEEN DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND THIS COULD
THEORETICALLY BE APPLIED TO
OTHER AS GIANT SECTION RATES
LIKE ON EVERY INCLUDE MEDIA. SO
FOR EXAMPLE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
COMPLETED TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
LESS AS TI TEST IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE THAN WE DID IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY. SO WHAT I THINK IS
THAT AND YOU IN GENERAL GENERAL
FUND ENOUGH FOCUSES ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF TESTING AND
SCREENING AND PILOTING NEW
TESTING METHODS LIKE I'D MENTION
PRIOR- WHETHER IT BE IN CLINIC
RAPID TESTING ARE. LEVERAGING AT
HOME TESTING SELF COLLECTION AND
MAKING THAT MARK SACHS
ACCESSIBLE FOR PATIENTS AND.
EDUCATING THEM ON THE NEED FOR
IT. WOULD BE SENT IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT. SO IF I MAY UM I'LL
PICK UP ON THE AT HOME AND THE
PATIENT SERVICE CENTER WE ONE OF
THINGS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
CLASS. IS YOU KNOW THE WAY TO
GET THAT THESE TO HELP- EVACUATE
SEES ANOTHER HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS- YEP MEET THE PATIENTS
WHERE THEY ARE AND IF WE CAN'T
DO IT AT THE HOME WE CAN DO IT.
YOU KNOW IN THE IN OUR PATIENT
SERVICE CENTERS AND WE HAVE WHAT
I THINK THE IMPORTANT THIRTY
PATIENT SERVICE CENTERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND WE
YEARS THAT YOU HAVE NOW- FOR-
COLLECTION. SO RATHER THAN HAVE
THEM COME TO THE- THE SITE YEAH
A LOT OF FOLKS. CAN'T GET THERE
BECAUSE THE WORKER. IT'S HARD
TRANSPORTATION ANY NUMBER OF
REASONS- YOU KNOW THEY CAN GO TO
A LOCAL PSC PATIENTS SERVICE
CENTER AND HOPEFULLY WITHIN THE
NEXT YEAR WILL BE MOVING INTO A
HOME COLLECTION. AND THEN WE
WILL WE NEED TO GET BETTER
ALIGNMENT YES SIR. I'M SURE WHAT
WE COULD DO IT I THINK YOU.
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION OF BETTER
ALIGNED OF REESE. AND FOCUSING
ON ON PREVENTION. OUT WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE
IF YOU WILL OKAY I THINK WE NEED
TO CHANGE THE MINDSET AROUND THE
US- AND CO THAT IS ACCELERATED A
LOT OF THAT AND I SEE THIS IS A
GREAT TIME TO. DISINTEGRATE
TITLE DISRUPTION BUT ALSO A
GREAT TIME TO LEAD BECAUSE WE
SEE PATIENTS WILL EMBRACE
TELEHEALTH BELUM BURKE BRACE NON
HOSPITAL BASED. YOU KNOW CARE
THEY'LL EMBRACE NON HOSPITAL
BASED OR NON CLINIC BASED.
TESTING AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO GET OUR
HEAD AROUND AND ALSO WITH ARMY
WE HAVE A HUGE COMMITMENT. THE
QUESTION I YOU KNOW. TO REALLY
TAKE CARE OF EVERYBODY I MEAN
ALL THAT AND- AND THAT'S THAT'S
A YOU KNOW WE'RE FOR A BIG
COMMERCIAL LAB TO HAVE THAT-
DEEP THE POPUP PART FELT-
COMMITMENT TO. DIVERSITY TO THE-
HEALTH INEQUITIES IS A BIG DEAL
AND THAT'S THAT'S WHERE WE WANT
TO THAT'S. WHERE WE WANT TO STEP
UP AND HELP. THANK YOU DR CITY
ANYTHING ON THIS- I DO HAVE TO
AGREE MICHAEL HERE AND SEE THAT
HER BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT- NEW
WAYS OF PROVIDING PROVIDE CARE
BE FOR. I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
DATA TO SHOW THAT PATIENTS ARE
ACTUALLY QUITE GOOD AT IT- DOING
AT HOME TESTING SO THINGS LIKE
SELL STOPS FOR GONORRHEA
CHLAMYDIA EVENED OUT STOP OUT
SOMETHING SHOWN TO BE PRETTY- SO
IF WE HAD. WOULD SUPPORT THOSE
KINDS OF MEASURES- I WILL SAY
THAT I THINK THAT. THERE'S JUST
A LOT OF HESITANCY- AND I'M SURE
EVERYBODY IS AWARE OF THAT
SURROUNDING. AT HEALTH CARE
CURRENTLY I THINK THAT. A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE FEELING VERY
DISTRUSTFUL. OF MEDICINE AT THE
MOMENT AND SCIENCE AT THE
MOMENT- AND I THINK THAT ONE OF
THE WAYS THAT WE CAN COMBAT THAT
TO GET PEOPLE SEEKING CARE AGAIN
IS JUST TO BE PROUD THAT I THINK
PLANNED PARENTHOOD DOES A REALLY
GREAT JOB OF BEING. LIKE IN THE
COMMUNITY BEING SUPER PRESIDENT-
AND BEING AND KNOWING RESOURCE
FOR PATIENTS TO SEEK CARE FOR-
AND SO SIR SUPPORTING UNITY-
INVOLVEMENT AND SUPPORTING YOU
KNOW- A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
CLINICIANS HAVING ADDITIONAL
TRUST AND IN- IN THE COMMUNITY
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO OVERCOME
A LOT OF THE HESITANCY THAT
PEOPLE ARE HAVING. TO SEEK THEIR
CARE. I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THANK YOU I AM-
LEARNED EARLIER THIS YEAR ABOUT
AT HOME RAPE KITS- AND IT WAS TO
YOUR POINT I THINK WE'RE
REVOLUTIONIZING THE WAY. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE HEALTH CARE AND
ESPECIALLY SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT TO RECEIVE. HEALTH
CARE- MOTIONAL AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAS DOCTOR WISHES
THAT DISRUPT THE SYSTEM IN A
POSITIVE WAY THAT ALLOWS MORE
PEOPLE TO SEEK CARE TAXES CARED
TO HAVE. CARE WITH THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED- SO THANK YOU ALL I
WANT I JUST THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE FOR HELPING US LEARN SO
MUCH ABOUT AND WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON THE GROUND AND HOW WE CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT. AT AND YOU
KNOW I HOPE THAT THIS CAN
CONVERSATION CONTINUES AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS-
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE GETS THE
CARE WHEN THEY NEED IT. AND NOT
HAVING THE BEARS THAT WE'RE
SEEING TODAY TO ACCESS TO CARE
AT THE MOMENT WHEN IT WOULD BE
AT MOST HELPFUL. TO RECEIVE IT
SO- THANK YOU ALL I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH EACH OF YOU ON
SOLVING THESE PROBLEMS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR GUIDANCE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. RIGHT SO IS
OKAY MATTER CHAIR WAS OFF NOW
YES. YOU CAN BEING OKAY. TO NEXT
YEAH I'M PRETTY SURE. THAT YOU
FIND OUT. IN HEY WE GOING TO
MOVE TOURISTS PANEL WHICH-
HEALTH CARE FOR PREGNANT PEOPLE
IN CODE RED WE'RE GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON THE PARTICULAR
CHALLENGES THE COVE IT HAS
PRESENTED FOR PREGNANT PEOPLE
AND THEY WERE FACING A MYRIAD OF
HEALTH STRESSES OUTSIDE OF BEING
PREGNANT PREGNANCY- AND THE
POSSIBILITY OF GIVING BIRTH WASJUST AN ADDED STRESS DURING A
PANDEMIC AND WE KNOW THAT THIS
ADD TO SOMEWHERE BONTA IS POINT
BLACK AND LATINO COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR WERE BOTH HIT HARD BY
THE PANDEMIC AND THEN DEEPLY
AFFECTED BY. THE LACK OF ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE- BIG ON GOING
CRISIS OF HIGH MATERNAL
MORTALITY AND MEDICAL RACISM AND
THAT IS EXPERIENCED- I KNOW THAT
WE AS A LEGISLATURE WORKED
INCREDIBLY HARD ON THIS- BOTH AS
SUPERVISOR MITCHELL NOW
SUPERVISOR MUCH ON HER WORK IN
THE LEGISLATURE- AND ALSO AT
SENATOR NANCY SKINNER WHO
AUTHORED SB SIXTY FIVE LAST YEAR
ALSO KNOWN AS THE MOM OF THIS
BILL WHICH I DID INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENTS INTO THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH I'M
PROVIDERS LIKE DO AS NURSE
MIDWIVES AND POSTPARTUM CARE I'M
ACTUALLY AN EFFORT THAT ALAMEDA
COUNTY THAT BOTH THAT SOMEWHERE
BONTA AND I HAVE THE HONOR OF.
REPRESENTING THEY HAVE BEEN HARD
AT WORK AT THIS FOR MANY YEARS
AND SO IT'S FUN TO SEE IT COME
TO THE STATE LEVEL- BUT IN THIS
PANEL WE WILL HEAR FROM
ADVOCATES AND PROVIDERS TO GIVE
A SENSE OF CODES ONGOING IMPACT
FOR MOTHERS PARENTS AND PREGNANT
PEOPLE AND WITH THAT I WANT TO
TURN IT OVER TO THE PANELISTS
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AND WE HAVE
WITH US ON THIS PANEL LEAN
CHRISSY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH ACCESS
WE HAVE KERIS JOHN JEAN WHO IS A
BIRTH DOULA. AND EDUCATOR
ADVOCATE WITH PERRIS MALOOF RACY
ANIME PRESIDENT AND PROVIDER AND
WE HAVE WHEN I AM OUT I BE ECHO
POLICY ANALYST FOR BLACK WOMEN
WELLNESS AND WE WILL START WITH
YOU- LEN CHRISSY IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND TELLING US A BIT ABOUT YOUR
WORK AND HOW THE WORK HAS. BEEN
GENERALLY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. I'M HAPPY TO- I DO IT
YOUR SLICE IN THE- AND- WHEN I
AS FAMILIAR WITH WHETHER SO. SEE
HOW THIS WORKS. YOU SHOULD GET
BUTTON. HE. THERE YOU GO WE. YOU
CAN SEE THE SLIDES ONLY. OKAY
GREAT I SEE SOME OF YOUR TOO SO
THAT'S GREAT- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ONE PERSON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS IN LOS ANGELES
WHERE SOCIAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATION AND POLICY
ORGANIZATION LOCATED. IN LA BUT
WITH THE STATE MY POLICY REACH
I'M PLEASED AND HONORED TO BE
WITH YOU TO TALK ABOUT THESE
ISSUES TODAY WITH MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE PANEL WE WORK MOSTLY WITH
PEOPLE ON MEDICARE- MEDICARE
ACCESS AND PER CALIFORNIA WHICH
ALL TOGETHER COVER ABOUT HALF
THE PRICE THE STATE'S
PREGNANCIES I FOUNDED THIS
ORGANIZATION IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WHEN THEY ARE BIRDS WERE
TAKING PLACE IN THE HALLS OF L.
A. USC AT THE COUNTY AND AT THAT
TIME THAT. INSTITUTION DELIVERED
ABOUT ONE OUT OF EVERY TWENTY
BIRDS IN THAT COUNTRY IT TOOK
SIX WEEKS TO SIX MONTHS TO GET A
FIRST PRENATAL APPOINTMENT AND
ALL WE HAD WAS COUNTY SERVICES
IN AMERICA WHICH DIDN'T COVER
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE SO WE HAVE
COME A LONG LONG WAY. AND
PLEASED TO SAY THAT WE ARE MANY
CALENDAR WE DO ENROLLMENT AND
TRAINING UP TO ORGANIZATIONS
ABOUT HOW THESE PROGRAMS WORK-
WE HAD A CASE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
FOR PREGNANT WOMEN AND FAMILIES
AFFECT PEOPLE FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS THE PROVIDE SUPPORT. UP TO
TWO YEARS AND WE HAVE A HOME
VISIT PROGRAM WHICH SEES ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND FAMILIES YEAR MOST
OF THE MARLETTE NECKS AND ABOUT
15% ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN- HIGHER
THANK YOU GENERAL HERE. WE ALL
CLASSES AND SUPPORT GROUPS. BY
DOWN AND COULD OUTREACH FOR
PREVENTION BUT- WE ARE. TO GET
OUR PROVIDER. 38% OF PREGNANT
WHO ARE BACKS. MUCH WOULD
PROVIDE FREE MAN FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE. APART DURING HOPE. FROM AND
SO OVER MANY SUPPORTS NOT EXIST
FOR COULD NOT BE AT. OR COVERT
KNOW IT'S LIKE WE'RE TALKING THE
KIND ABSOLUTELY NOT BY TALKING
ABOUT IT MORE TO A LOT. AND
COMING OUT OF LOOKED- HELLO.
PEOPLE I MET WE'RE NOT THE BEST
OF. BEFORE CORPORATE WE CAN SAY
THAT THE- WHO ALSO THE SAME BUT
- BUT ARE NOT IN CAL THEY
PRIVATE AND- THROUGH WORK OR A-
INSURANCE. OR BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW THEY CAN MOVE OUT OF IN CAP
OR COVER CALIFORNIA INTO THREE
MEDIC HEALTH SO OUR
COMMUNICATION THERE IS NOT THE
GREATEST. THIS GREAT DISPLAYS AN
AVERAGE THREE YEARS TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY FIFTEEN WHICH
IS THE MOST RECENT STATE DATA.
BUT PUT INSECURITY AT THE TIME
WAS ABOUT 25% AND ALMOST 11% OF
PREGNANT PEOPLE EXPERIENCED
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. AND
WE ARE SURE WE WILL SEE HIGHER
PERCENTAGES THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE STATE SURVEYS.
BOB FOR HEALTH CARE MUCH HAS
ALREADY BEEN SAID BUT I WILL ADD
THAT BEFORE THE VACCINE IN
PERSON VISITS WERE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE- VISITS IT REALLY DO
HAVE TO BE IN PERSON FOR CANCER
DETECTION FOR BROKEN BONES ABOUT
LIKE. FOR A POSSIBLE- AT HOME
TEST ABSOLUTELY AND CAUSING A
DISRUPTION I LOVE THAT TERM BOB
BUT IT TOOK US THREE MONTHS TO
GET OR ORTHOPEDIC CONSOLE FOR A
WOMAN WHO FELL DOWN THE STAIS.
ON THE STAIRS I THINK UP IN LATE
TWENTY TWENTY. RECENT EXPLOSION
AND DIABETES IN THE AREA PEOPLE
WHO ARE WHO HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
STAY INDOORS AND FOR THE MOST
PART ARE. EXERCISING LASSEN
INCREASING YOUR SCREEN SCREEN
TIME- COMMUNICATION THAT LEADS
FROM THE STATE- WERE NONEXISTENT
BECAUSE I ASK WHAT ARE THE
GUIDELINES FOR SEEING. PEOPLE
DURING PREGNANCY- SOME PROVIDERS
FOR SEEING PEOPLE EVERY OTHER
VISIT SOME SET UP WELL THAT
STUDENTS ARE TRIMESTER- AND
MAYBE THEIR WORK REGULAR
PROVISION BUSINESS PROVIDED
SOMEONE WAS HIGH RISK AND EVEN
NOW IN OUR AREA. LOCAL PROVIDERS
ONLY SEEING WOMEN WHO. ARE
PREGNANT PEOPLE ONLINE UP UNTIL
THE THIRD TRIMESTER AND HAD REAL
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS. TELEHEALTH
HAS BEEN A HUGE IMPROVEMENT I
NOTICED- THAT LOOK DIFFERENT
TAKE ON THIS THAT ARE PRIOR.
ANALYSTS BUT- ARE ONLY AND EVEN
OUR OWN COMPLICITY PROGRAM IS
INCREASE INCREDIBLY. BECAUSE IT
IS IT'S A VIRTUAL. BUT WE ARE
MEDICAL. AND THE PRODUCT AND RED
FLAG NEEDS BE WORKED OUT FOR ME
. THIS ONLINE I ASK ANY STATE
FUND PROVIDE. HAVE TO SEE
SOMEONE IN PERSON AT NOW IT THAT
PREFERRED. ORBITS AND- BECAUSE
OF THE- WHAT WE SEE IN THE DAY.
THE BIGGEST COMMUNICATE I WOULD
IS THE BILL YOUR TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW MEDICARE OPTIONS. I WAS
PREGNANCY AND SHOULDN'T BECAUSE
OFF THIS IS THE CASE SINCE APRIL
TWO TWENTY- AND IT'S ALSO THE
CASE FOR YOUNG UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE REACH AGE TWENTY SIX MW
BECAUSE- THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
COULD CHANGE. SO WE SHOULD SEE
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT YEAR
OLD UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE ON MEDI
CAL- INCOME INCREASED REPORTS
WORK- IF WE HAD REALLY DONE
THAT. INSTEAD THE PROVIDERS HAVE
ACCEPTED THAT MEDICARE.
HYPERTENSIVE WOMEN COULD BE ABLE
. AUSTIN'S COULD BE REMOVED
WHATEVER CHRONIC SITUATION EXIST
COULD CONTINUE TO GET CARE. AND
I'M GRATEFUL IT AND HAVE BEEN A
PART OF THE POST. PARTUM TWELVE
MONTH MOVEMENT- WITH SB SIXTY
FIVE IN THE BUDGET- BUDGET WORK
THANK. THAT IS REALLY EXISTED
ALREADY IN THE STATE FOR THE
LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND NO ONE
CLEARLY AND EFFECTIVELY TOLD
THOSE MOST IN NEED WERE JUST
STARTING TO GET NOTICES FROM THE
STATE. WE ARE WE ARE-
CIRCULATING THAT SAYING MEDICAL
SHOULD CONTINUE AND YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO SEE PREGNANT WAS
PREGNANT. PEOPLE FOR EVERYTHING
THEY- ARE WE REALLY A GREAT A
CULTURE SUPPORT FOR PRACTICE
THAT'S- WHATEVER HAVE. COME ON
IN YOU TO BE SEEN CAUGHT A LOT
TO THE CHILL HELP WHAT IT IS YOU
. YOU ARE SO. BY TERM AWAY- WE-
CAN'T DID SEND AN ARTS TELLING
PEOPLE ABOUT. MAN HEALTH A
COVERS ALL. RELATED CARE RECALL
. OF INCOME AND- OF IMMIGRATION
. WELL KEPT. FIRST WHAT IS
CONSIDERED PEOPLE SCREW TO BUY
THE SAYS L. DPO JUST FOR A ROTH
INCLUDES IT'S A- IN LA BEFORE
AFTER THE PANDEMIC ON MAJORITY
OF THE DAY EXPERIENCE WOULD. IN
TO JULY TWENTY WE'RE- HALFORD
PRAYER AND MORE THAN WHICH PAYER
- ARE FOOD WERE ALMOST AS LIKELY
TO BEEN INFECTED BY KOBE. AND
BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SEVEN
PER. PEOPLE WHO CAN GET HELP. OR
NOT IT. WELCOME DIGITAL DIVIDE
WASN'T ISN'T HUGE HERE TO READ
THE PROGRAM WE SPENT A LOT OF
HOURS PEOPLE OUT HIS AND HARD TO
UPLOAD DOC TO TAKE PICTURES AND
ALL THESE PEOPLE PEOPLE HAD TO
SCRAMBLE AND RUN FROM PLACE TO
PLACE AND TRY TO. INTERJECT OR
DOES THAT WERE CRASHING AND- IT
WAS VERY DEPRESSING IN THE SKIRT
DEMORALIZING. WE'RE HAPPY FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS BUT- TOOK A LOT.
AND THEN WE'RE WE WERE EXTREMELY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE FUNDING FROM
PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS BUT WE HAD
TO USE COMMERCIAL DELIVERY
SERVICES TO GET THAT FOOD TO
PEOPLE- AND WE HAD TO CUT INTO
OUR OWN GRANTS TO PAY DELIVERY
FEES IT WORKED THERE AREN'T
REALLY DELIVERED FOOD THERE
ISN'T REALLY DELIVERED FOOD FOR
OTHER THAN SENIORS- EVEN TELL
FRESH WHICH THANKFULLY STARTED
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO ORDER FROM
GROCERY STORES- YOU STILL HAD TO
PAY FEES. AND FOR THAT I WOULD
SAY THAT'S A THAT'S A BIG
RECOMMENDATION CUT THROUGH THOSE
FEES FOR PEOPLE ON HEALTH
QUESTIONS AT LEAST FOR KOHLBERG.
AFFECTED. PEOPLE ACT OF
PREGNANCY. SO IN ADDITION TO ITS
CULTURE SUPPORT PROGRESS PEOPLE-
OUR ANSWERS THE STATE'S
CONFERENCE OF TECHNICAL SERVICES
PROGRAM. PROVIDED ADEQUATELY AND
ALL PRENATAL PROGRAMS MEDICAID
ALL IN CAPS EVEN COVER
CALIFORNIA IT'S FEDERALLY
MATCHED MEDICO. THAT PROVIDES
ASSESSMENTS EXTRA MESTRE AND-
POST PARTUM. AND- IT DID THIS IS
ASSESSMENTS COVER EDUCATION. AND
PSYCHOSOCIAL SERVICES AND WE
FOCUS ON THE LATTER THE MOST
THESE ARE THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
ASSESSING FOR FOOD SECURITY
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS NEED FOR
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING ARE YOU
BEING BEAT INCOME. AND THEN
FOLLOWING UP THE WORK FORCE TO
FOLLOW UP ON THESE ISSUES. WE
HAVE A REPORT ON THE NEED FOR-
BETTER OVERSIGHT OF THIS PROGRAM
HOW TO MAXIMIZE THE PROGRAM WITH
A LOT OF RECOMMENDATIONS I WOULD
BUY YOU TO LOOK AT SOME POINT
I'M HAPPY TO SEND IT TO YOUR
SEND YOU THE LINKS OF HAPPENS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESET TYPE AND I
SAID A LOT I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION. THANKS THEY GIVE US
KERR THAT WAS AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING DOWN IN.
THE AREA IS REALLY IMPORTANT SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- ON THAT
TURNED OVER TO. CURRYS GEOLOGY
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR
WORK AND WHAT YOU'VE SEEN DURING
THE PANDEMIC. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING THE SPACE
TO HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS IT.
DOES MY HEART GOOD- I BECAME A
DILEMMA IN THE LATE NINETIES IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AS A-
MATTER OF FACT- WHEN I WAS
WORKING FOR BRITAIN PROJECT USA.
AND AT THAT TIME WE KNEW THAT
PLATFORMS IN AB MORE TWO THREE.
EVEN UP TO SIX TIMES AND LESS
LIKELY. TO LIVE TO SEE THEIR
FIRST BIRTHDAYS AS BABIES THAT
AMOUNTS OR THAT MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO HAVE. A DEATH OR NEAR DEATH
EXPERIENCES AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
AT LIKE THIRTY FIVE YEARS. OF
KNOWING. THIS ALREADY AND- IT IS
NOT FASTER AND- TO SEE NOW M.
OUR- POLICY MAKE. KIND OF CATCH
UP TO WHAT THAT MEANS AND WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE CURRENTLY I AM
ABLE TO BE A PART OF A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT IS A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN BLUESHIELD CALIFORNIA
BLACK MOTHERS UNITED HER HEALTH
FIRST. HEALTH CONDITION I'M TO
BE ABLE TO ALLOW. THAT ALSO ACTS
AS A PREGNANCY WHAT'S- ALSO IS
ABLE TO BE A SISTER FRIEND WHICH
DEVOID WORKING POINT CONCEPT BUT
IT IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. MMHM SO BASICALLY
ADAM AFTER MORE THAN. TWENTY
YEARS IN THIS FIELD. RIGHT ATTY
TRACK FOR ME TO BE ABLE PRINT
SERVE TO THE MOM- STILL MY
ANIMALS AND SO THAT IS THE ONE
DEPENDENT AMAZING AT. OF COURSE
IT HAS COINCIDED WITH PREVENT SO
I AM DEFINITELY LOOKING FORWARD
TO HAVING FURTHER CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE IMPACTS M. THAT A
PANDEMIC HAS ON SYSTEMS THAT ARE
ALREADY. FRAGILE AND
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE ALREADY
FRAGILE BETWEEN COMMUNITIES AND
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS DEBATE ON
HAVE ACCESS TO. THANK YOU FOR
THAT INTRODUCTION I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING COMPETITION TO-
MISS- LEWISBURG L. TURNOVER TEO. THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
PARRIS MOVED VERY AND I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION A
NINE- THE CALIFORNIA'S MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IT IS AN AFFILIATE
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF NURSE
MIDWIVES AND IN THIS STATE WE
WORK ON ADVOCACY FOR THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE INCLUDING- WOMEN
BIRTHING PEOPLE- OUT COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS FOR THE MIDWIFERY AT
PROFESSION. WHILE WORKING TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO MIDWIFERY
CARE TO IMPROVE MATERNAL CHILD
HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES- WITH A
VERY SPECIFIC FOCUS ON REDUCING
RACISM BASED DISPARITIES
INCREASING. EQUITY AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IN OUR
STATE- I'M ALSO A MOTHER- AND
I'M ALSO A MIDWIFE I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO I WORK IN DAVIS I'VE
BEEN PROVIDING CARE FOR WOMEN
AND FAMILIES BIRTHING PEOPLE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE. IN
VARIOUS ROLES- AS A NURSE AS A
LACTATION CONSULTANT AS A
CHILDBIRTH EDUCATOR AS AN
ADVOCATE- AND AS A MIDWIFE AND
IT'S SUCH AN HONOR TO GET TO BE. A PART OF THE SCANDAL TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'M AN-
LASTLY. THE EIGHT YEAH WE AND
PLEASE ENTER YOURSELF. AMERICAN
EVERYONE AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HAVING GOTTEN BONUS AND MYSELF-
AND GIVING US THE SPACE AND
FOREIGN TO US SHARE OUR
EXPERIENCES AND I THOUGHT I WILL
TRY AND SHARE MY SCREEN- I JUST
HAVE A FEW SLIDES THAT MIGHT
MAKE- MAYBE THAT MIGHT MAKE. OH
GOODNESS. OKAY PERHAPS NOT
GETTING OUR SHARE. HERO HE THAT
AIN'T. FORGIVE ME OKAY HAPPENS
TO THE BEST OF US. HELLO WHY DID
EVERYTHING OKAY WELL. ARE YOU
SHOULD HAVE TO SHARE I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU SEE AT. SANTA
BARBARA MONUMENT- AT THE- SENATE
NEXT TO START VIDEO- YES OKAY SO
WHEN I CLICK FAT WHEN YOU CLICK
OPEN SYSTEMS I GET A- BUZZ BOX
THE TEXT BOX THAT SAYS OPEN
SYSTEMS PREFERENCES OKAY IT
MIGHT BE A WHOLE THINGS SO- GOSH
MAYBE I'LL LEAVE THAT OUT I
WE'VE GOT OUT AND IF SOMETHING
COMES UP WE'LL- IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME. IT SUCKS KEEPMOAT- YEAH
OKAY SORRY SO I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT- MY NAME IS ON THE MOVIE
CARE ACT AND I AM A POLICY
ANALYST WITH A **** FOR WELLNESS
AND BLACKMAN FOR HONEST ACTION
PROJECT- AND AHEAD OF TOPIC THAT
TALKS THAT. BREAKS DOWN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HE TWO BLACK
ONE FOR WELLNESS IS A FIVE OH
ONE SEE THREE AT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION AND TALKING POINTS
ACTION PROJECT IS THE SISTER
ORGANIZATION AND HOLDS A FIVE
ONE THREE FOUR STATUS AND I LIKE
TO SHARE THIS HISTORY OF BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS BEFORE IT WAS
INCORPORATED AS A FIVE ONE TWO
THREE IT STARTED OFF AS WITH A
PROGRAM CALLED THE XIN GHAZI
PROGRAM AND- THAT SOME GUYS THE
IS A SWAHILI WORD THAT WHEN
TRANSLATED INTO ENGLISH MEANS
AREN'T. AND THAT PROGRAM
ACTUALLY PAIRED PREGNANT PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY WITH MENTORS
ARE ON THAT- WOULD TO SORT OF
GUIDE THEM AND SUPPORT THEM AND
OFFER YOU KNOW GUIDANCE AND
ASSISTANCE THROUGH ARM THEIR
PREGNANCY AND UP TO A YEAR POST
PARTUM- AND SOUL WITH THIS IN.
THE EARLY NINETIES. BUT BLOCKING
HOMELESSNESS IN FACT IN. WAS
THIS IS INSECTS OF THE OR- AND
SO FOR YEARS AFTER THIS YOUNG
GHAZI PER. THE OR- DECIDE TO-
BECOME OFFICIAL AND CREATE WHAT
IS NOW BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS
AND SO- IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
WE RECEIVED FIVE OH ONE SEE
THREE STATUS- AND SORT OF
STARTED TO WORK AND MOVE
UPSTREAM TO ADDRESS SYSTEMS AND
POLICY- TO SUPPORT THE HEALTH OF
. OUR FOCUS GROUP BLACK WOMEN
BLACK PARTY PEOPLE RIGHT- AND SO
THE ACTION PROJECT IS THE FIBER
ONCE BEFORE AND THAT IS OUR
WHERE A LOT OF OUR POLITICS AND
OUR POLITICAL WORKING OUR
LEFTOVER WORK COMES OUT BUT
THAT'S ALSO WHERE OUR POLICY
STATES AND SO. I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE THAT- AND SO WERE THE ONLY
REFLECTIVE JUSTICE FACULTY FOR
CALIFORNIA- WHICH IS HUGE AND
THEN THE NEXT ONE I HAD WAS A
BEAUTIFUL SLIDE THAT DEFINED
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND TO MEAN
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE- AND IT'S
HUMAN RIGHT TO CONTROL OUR
SEXUALITY OR GENDER OR WORK. IN
A REPRODUCTION AND THAT RIGHT
CAN ONLY BE ACHIEVED WHEN ALL
WOMEN AND GIRLS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETE ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND
POLITICAL POWER AND RESOURCES TO
MAKE HEALTHY DECISIONS ABOUT OUR
BODIES OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES IN ALL AREAS OF OUR
LIVES. AND SO THAT DEFINITION
THAT FRAMEWORK GROUNDS ALL OF
OUR WORK AND IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH FIELD THERE IS THIS-
CONCEPT HEALTH IN ALL POLICIES
RIGHT AND SO YOU KNOW WE'RE
LOOKING WHEN WE CREATE POLICIES
WE'RE LOOKING TO ADDRESS HEALTH
IN ALL OF THOSE POLICIES THAT WE
CREATE SO AS. TO ACHIEVE YOU
KNOW. GREAT PUBLIC HEALTH OR
WHAT RIGHT AND SO FOR US WE LOOK
AT IT IS R. J. AND ALL POLICIES
WE TAKE THAT APPROACH SO AS TO
ENSURE THAT WE ADVOCATE FOR AN
ADVANCE POLICIES THAT ARE
HOLISTIC. INTERSECTIONAL AND
REFLECT THE BASIC TENETS OF
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE. FROM SO
UNDERSTANDING THAT WERE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS THE NEXT SLIDE I
HAD WAS. EXPLAINING IT WAS A
CHART THAT SORT OF HIGHLIGHTS
THE CURRENT LANDSCAPE OF
MATERNAL HEALTH UP IN
CALIFORNIA. RIGHT AND SO I
JUXTAPOSED THESE TWO CHARTS ONE
IS A COMPARISON BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND HOW CALIFORNIANS
DOING AS COMPARED TO THE REST OF
THE UNITED STATES WHEN IT COMES
TO OVERALL MATERNAL. HEALTHCARE
OR MATERNAL MORTALITY RATE AND
THAT CHART ALLOWS CALIFORNIA TO
CLAP FOR ITSELF IMPACTS OPENED
BACK BECAUSE WE ARE DOING SO
WE'RE FARING BETTER. RATE AS THE
DATA STANDS THEM THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AND THEN THE SECOND
CHART THAT I HAVE JUXTAPOSED.
NEXT TO IT ON THIS. ON THE SLIDE
IF YOU ONLY A- IS A COMPARISON
RIGHT IT TAKES A CLOSER LOOK OF
THE STOCKS WITHIN CALIFORNIA AND
COMPARES- BIRTHING PEOPLE OF
VARIOUS RACES AND WHAT THAT
REVEALS IS YOU KNOW- I'M MORE
DISCONCERTING AND DISHEARTENING
STORY RIGHT- WE SEE THAT BLACK
WORKING PEOPLE- SUFFERED.
TREMENDOUSLY RATE THE DISPARITY
IN XP GREEN JUST AT THIS POINT
AND SO- A RECENT ACTUALLY
REPORT- BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH THAT
WAS JUST RELEASED- IN SEPTEMBER
I BELIEVE- REVEALED THAT BETWEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE PREGNANCY RELATED
MORTALITY RATIO FOR BLACK WOMEN
WAS FIFTY SIX POINT TWO. LIVE
BIRTHS FOUR HUNDRED THAT. FIFTY
SIX POINT TWO DEATHS PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND LIVE BIRDS RIGHT- ARM
AND THAT'S THAT MAKES IT FOUR TO
SIX TIMES THAT OF OUR
COUNTERPARTS RIGHT AND THIS
NUMBER IS UP FROM FORTY FIVE
POINT THREE. DEATHS PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND LIVE BIRTHS FROM TWENTY
ELEVEN TO TWENTY THIRTEEN SO
WHAT THAT REVEALS RIGHT THESE
ARE THE MOST CURRENT NUMBERS
THAT WE HAVE IS THAT THIS
DISPARITY IS WIDENING. AND
THAT'S PROBLEMATIC RATE- AND WE
DO THAT THIS WAS THE CASE
BECAUSE THE COUNTY WIDE NUMBERS
SORT OF TELL US THIS RATE
DEPENDING ON WHAT COUNTY YOU ARE
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH OFFER MORE
RECENT DATA- WE SEE THE
DISPARITIES ARE EVEN GREATER
THAN. WHAT'S WHAT'S REVEALED
STATEWIDE SO- I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO SORT OF POINT THAT
OUT IN SHARE I THINK AND I
APOLOGIZE AND THEN MY LAST
SLIDE. WAS TO JUST SHARE THAT.
BLACK WELLNESS. OUR OUR MATURE
LIKE OUR RESPONSE HAS BEEN BOTH
PROGRAM. AND LET AND WORKING ON
- CHARLES RIGHT AND SO I WANTED
HIGHLIGHT THREE OF POLICY ONE OF
- ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER. SB FOUR SIX
FOUR RIGHT- SO WE'VE PASSED LIKE
THREE POLICIES- IN COALITION
WITH PHENOMENAL ORGANIZATION TO
RAPE AND EXCELLENT MIDWIVES
AROUND HERE GREAT PARTNERS- THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH. ADDRESSING THE
DISPARITIES IN MATERNAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR PERFECT PEOPLE
RIGHT BREAKING PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND SO I JUST WANT HIGH LIKE
THOSE THREE REALLY QUICKLY AND
THEN I'LL STEP BACK. SB FOUR SIX
FOUR WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
DIGNITY AND BURKE IN PREGNANCY
AND CHILDBIRTH ACT AUTHORED BY
BE PHENOMENAL AVENUE SENATOR
THEN SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. THE JUSTICE
AND EQUITY IN MATERNITY CARE ACT
WHICH- SOUGHT TO REMOVE
PHYSICIAN'S SUPERVISION VEST-
FOR OF MIDWIVES- THAT'S
EXPANDING ACCESS TO CARE
BECAUSE- MEMBERS LED THAT I HAD
SPOKE TO THE MATERNITY CARE
DESSERTS THAT ARE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE BY THERE ARE AT LEAST NINE
COUNTIES. THAT DON'T HAVE AN
OBGYN SO BY REMOVING THIS
PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION WE ALLOW
OTHER QUALIFIED PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE CARE AND FILL IN THOSE
GAPS- AND THEN WE HAVE OUR MOST
RECENT WIN SB SIXTY FIVE-
CALIFORNIA MOM THIS BILL.
AUTHORED SB TWELVE THREE SEVEN
WITH AUTHORED BY THE WILL DIE.
AND SB SIXTY FIVE A CALIFORNIA
MOM MISSED BILL AUTHORED BY THE
FOR. SENATORS AND- YOU KNOW AND
SOME MEMBER- YOU ALREADY. WHAT
ALL THAT DOES AND- EITHER SORT
OF A POLICY WAS- IN AN ATTACK
TO. WORK ON ELIMINATE THIS-
BECAUSE WE ALSO KNOW THAT A
NUMBER OF THESE DISPARITIES LIKE
A NUMBER OF THESE MATERNAL
DEATHS ARE IN FACT PER
PREVENTABLE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF THEM AND SO- ADDRESSING
ISSUES LIKE IMPLICIT BIAS AND
RACISM WHICH WE KNOW. TO BE
APPROVED BECAUSE OF A NUMBER OF
THESE DEATHS- IS CRITICAL AND SO
WE'RE WORKING TO ADDRESS THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE APOLOGIZE MUCH
MUCH LIGHTER COLORS. AND ANYWAY
THANK YOU THEM TO US SO THAT WE
CAN THEM OUT. THE YEAH NO THANK
YOU FOR THAT ONE INTRODUCTION
AND I KNOW BOTH OF US AND THE
REST OF THE MEMBERS ARE ACTUALLY
- FROM THERE FOR JOBS WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THOSE FIVE I KNOW IT IT'S
THE NUMBER I HEAR OFTEN THAT A
BLACK WOMAN IS FOUR TO SIX TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO DIE THAN I AM
DURING CHILDBIRTH BUT IT SHOCKS
HEAR IT SO I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT FACT
AND THE FACT THAT IT IS ONLY
GOTTEN WORSE DURING THE PANDEMIC
IS PART OF WHY WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION. AND FOR THOSE
EITHER LISTENING TO THE FIRST
PANEL WHEN DOCTORS WHO TASIA
TALKED ABOUT HER PATIENTS WHO
DIDN'T SEE CARE DESPITE HER
OVERWHELMING- DIABETES UNTIL
AFTER HALFWAY THROUGH HER
PREGNANCY WE START TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THE PANDEMIC EXACERBATES
THESE PROBLEMS AND WE NEED TO.
BE DOING EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR
POWER TO ENSURE INDIVIDUALS GET
ACCESS TO CARE- I HAVE TO SAY I
HAVE TO ASK A QUESTION WHICH IS
YOU STILL HAVE THE SHINGLES THE
PROGRAM. YOU SAID IT WAS A YEAR
BEGINNING BUT I WONDER I MEAN I
FEEL LIKE HAVING BEEN A PREGNANT
PERSON. AND SOMEONE WITH
INCREDIBLE CARE. I DON'T KNOW AN
ANTI PROGRAM IS JUST SUCH AN
AMAZING IDEA. READ AGREED
UNFORTUNATELY- IN THIS MOMENT WE
GAP OKAY MA'AM. BUT YOU KNOW IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE CAN'T. LOOK
FOR FIGHTING FOR HOME VISITATION
. AND I DO THAT'S RIGHT ONE OF
THE THINGS ARE WELL- I GET MY
SPELL WHICH WE KNOW AGAIN IT.
THE DATE ON LISTEN. TO DO AS A
SPECIAL FOR WOMEN OF. IS REALLY
INCREDIBLE AND HOW IT AFFECTS
MATERNAL MORTALITY AND BIRTH
OUTCOMES FOR THE UNBORN- SO. IT
AT FAN WAY TO PER AUNTIES. WE
CONTINUE THAT WORK AND WELL
THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT I THINK-
YOU KNOW WE'VE REALLY ALREADY
BEGUN TO HIGHLIGHT A LOT OF WHAT
THE PROBLEMS ARE- DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND SO- YOU KNOW AND I
THINK- SO WE ACT A KIA REALLY
TALKED AT THE END ABOUT THE
POLICY THAT IS PASSED IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS TARGETED AT THIS
ISSUE OF ACCESS AND REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND I GUESS I WOULD ASK
FOR ANY OF USE OF COMING TO THIS
POINT A PANDEMIC WHERE DOES NOT
OVER BUT WE IN OUR LIVING WITH
IT AND UNDERSTANDING HOW TO LIVE
WITH THAT- WHAT RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU HAVE FOR US FOR WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN FOR THESE INCREASED-
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES THAT ARE
HAPPENING FOR WOMEN ESPECIALLY
WOMEN OF COLOR. WHO ARE BIRTHING
- SO I GUESS I WILL START WITH-
WILL THE BACKWARDNESS BIKE YEAH
DO YOU WANT TO START. THANK YOU
. CASH SO MY I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS. APPROPRIATE OR IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE BUT EXPEDIENT ENOUGH
BUT I THINK STILL THAT- REALLY
ADDRESSING THESE BEES
DISPARITIES IN THESE ISSUES
THEIR POLICY IS CRITICAL- AND SO
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARMED WITH THEIR EARS TO THE
GROUND SORT OF INFORMING THE
POLICY ARM RECOMMENDATIONS AND-
IN STORE IN TURN THE LEGISLATION
THAT'S PASSED- IS A CRITICAL
STEP TOWARDS- ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES BECAUSE IT. CREATES
CHANGE ON A SYSTEMS WIDE LEVEL-
AND CAPTURES A BROADER- SECT OF
THE COMMUNITY- YOU KNOW AND SO
FOR ME I THINK I REALLY DO
BELIEVE IN POLICY- INNOVATIVE
POLICY POLICY THAT'S EXPENSIVE-
AND SORT OF PUSHES. DOWN IS
CRITICAL TO REVIEW THE EFFECTING
CHANGE IN THIS ARENA AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S TOO BIG. OF AN
ANSWER OR THAT'S NOT. IS
IMMEDIATE MAN THAT YOU KNOW YOU
MIGHT BE LOOKING FOR BUT I
REALLY DO BELIEVE IN THE POWER
OF- INNOVATIVE LEGISLATION TO.
YOU KNOW TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
. HI I'M MISS HERSEY LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S READY TO JUMP IN AND SHE
SAID SHE FELT PROCLAIMS HERSELF
A MEDIC CAL NERDS SO WE'LL TURN
IT OVER TO HER FOR WHAT SHE
THINKS WE CAN BE. DOING IN THIS
SPACE. I'M PROBABLY TURNING RED-
THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT ONE IS
THE YOU KNOW OUR OUR FAVORITE
PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN WITH US
SINCE THE MID EIGHTIES AND HAS-
IS EVIDENCE BASED- AND SUPPORTED
BY FEDERAL FUNDING AND THAT IS
CONFERENCE OF PERSONAL SERVICES-
WE DON'T OVERSEE IT WELL ENOUGH
AND- IT WOULD BE GREAT TO HAVE A
REAL DEEP DIVE INTO WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THAT PROGRAM- MANAGED
CARE IS NOW THE WAY OF THE WORLD
FOR MEDICAID ALL- PREGNANCIES IN
JANUARY ALL PREGNANCIES WILL BE
IN MANAGED CARE EXCEPT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED. WHICH DOES CONCERN
US THAT KIND OF SPLIT HOW WILL
THE CREATED MEDI CAL FOR A
DOCUMENT THAT IS NOT AS GOOD AS
THE MANAGED CARE WILL THAT BE
THAT PERCEPTION. BUT- S. DOES
THIS DETERMINANTS OF OR WHAT
WE'RE TO ABOUT HERE. THAT IS
WHAT CPSDOES THIS CEDARS PARK-
NEEDS AND SO THE FACT THAT
MANAGED CARE DOES NOT GENERALLY
THOSE SERVICES. ARE PLANNING FOR
IT THEIR INITIAL- HE WAS OR OR
OR- CAPITATION WAS INCREASED TO
INCLUDE CPS BEING AND THEY DON'T
REALLY DO IT- SO WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO LOOK INTO THAT- I WOULD
ALSO SAY THE THINGS I SAID.
DURING THE PRESENTATION RICHARD
YOU KNOW CUT FEES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT- DELIVERY FOR
CALFRESH- PROVIDE HOME DELIVERY
FOR PEOPLE WHO CAN'T GET OUT OR
SHOULD NOT GET OUT- TELL PEOPLE
THAT MEDICARE CONTINUES. EMBRACE
PREGNANCY AND- THEN THE NEED FOR
NOT NOT TO BE PREGNANT IF
SOMEBODY CHOOSES NOT TO BE AND
SAY YOU CAN GET THAT IT'S OKAY-
BUT- LET'S NOT TURN PEOPLE AWAY
WHO HAVE A NEED BECAUSE THE
PROVIDERS AFRAID OF NOT GETTING.
PAID AND WE SEE THAT WAY WAY WAY
TOO MUCH INTERRUPTIONS IN
COVERAGE. WHICH SHOULD NOT BE
HAPPENING BUT THEY DO. AND
THERE'S NOT A CULTURE- AGAIN AND
LIKE LET'S JUST SEE PEOPLE
ANYWAY. LET'S LET'S TRY TO SET
THAT WILL TAKE CARE OF HER.
BECAUSE I'M SURE THE PROVIDERS
DON'T GET PAID OFF AND IN THE
BIG STEP THEY CAN'T A PRODUCT
THAT WAY. SO YOU KNOW THE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS. I GO TO-
AND THEN I. HOW WE ARE WE GET TO
US ARE WE GET A- WHAT CAN WE TO
IMPROVE. CARE FOR WOMEN PROVED.
FOR WOMEN PREGNANT PEOPLE NEED
TO. KNOW IF THERE'S ANY WHO'S
NOT BE GO COLD- IT'S PREGNANT
PEOPLE AND HOW CAN WE TELL
PROVIDE. THIS IS TURNING INTO
DOES BECAUSE I HEARD THAT EVEN
FROM. A MINISTER OF THESE
PROGRAM WELL YOU KNOW WE CAN'T.
WE CAN'T LIKE THE BOAT WITH THE
HOSPITALS AND WE CAN'T DO THIS
THE CLINICS WILL YOU CANNOT IT'S
- OR DEATH LET'S REALLY. PRESS
THAT WE DO NOT WANT PREGNANT
PEOPLE STAY WITH COBRA AND WE
WANT YOU TO GET THESE
VACCINATIONS. SO TRANSPOSER
MIGHT. YOU. RECOMMENDATIONS A
YOU MISS GARCIA AT IN THE FOR
PANEL IT. IT COMES UP OFTEN IN
CONGRESS AROUND REPRODUCTIVE
CARE THERE'S NO QUESTION THE
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT IS. TOP
OF THE LIST FOR INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE WITHOUT PROPER
REIMBURSEMENT AND PAYMENT WE
DON'T HAVE THE PROVIDERS OR
ACCESS TO THE CARE AS YOU
MENTIONED OF AN ATTITUDE OF JUST
COME AND LET ME TAKE CARE OF YOU
LET ME SEE- AND- ENDS WITHOUT
THE MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT OF
TELEHEALTH. RIGHT I KNOW THERE
IS A LOT OF HAVING AGAIN BEEN
PREGNANT THREE TIMES MYSELF I
UNDERSTAND THE BENEFIT OF BEING
IN THE ROOM WITH YOUR PHYSICIAN.
BUT IF IT PROVIDES ACCESS TO
SOMEONE WHO OTHERWISE WOULDN'T
LOCK IN RATE AND TELEHEALTH IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT- TOOL IN THE
ARSENAL ENSURING EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO CARE FOR NOT
REIMBURSING FOR IT AND IT'S NOT.
REALISTIC TOOL- SO THANK YOU FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THAT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT- AND NOW MISS
JACKIE DO YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING ON. WHAT SHOULD WE BE
FOCUSING ON IN THIS MOMENT. L.
AND MY MINDSET IS ALWAYS AT PRE
PANDEMIC BUT ALSO POST PANDEMIC
SO ALL MY ANSWERS ARE AT. IT THE
APPLY NOW WEBER IN THIS CRISIS
BUT THEY DON'T STOP WHEN THE
CRISIS HAS BEEN MANAGED OR
MITIGATED AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WOULD IMPLORE FOLKS WHO
DO THE POLICY WORK WHO CREATE
THESE EMIGRATE IF WAYS TO
ADDRESS RACISM AND BIAS AND ALL
OF THESE THINGS- THAT THAT YOU
ENSURE THAT THE LANGUAGE.
DOESN'T ZAENTZ AND BARRIERS TO
THE FOLKS WHO ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS WORK THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DOING THAT THIS IS
DEFENDING OF THE AUNTIES YOU
KNOW BREAKING PROJECT IS FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND
THAT WAS THE WHOLE CONCEPT WAS
PREGNANT WOMEN. BEING SISTERS TO
PREGNANT WOMEN BECAUSE WHO YOU
TELL EVERYTHING TO YOUR BIG
SISTER RIGHT NOT SOME PERSON ON
CROSSTOWN WHO DOESN'T KNOW YOU
FROM ADAM YOU KNOW IT WAS ONLY
GOING TO SEE YOU FOR THREE AND A
HALF OF THE SEVEN MINUTES. THAT
IS YOUR APPOINTMENT SLOT- I
THINK THAT IT IS IN A LOT OF
WAYS I'M FAIR TO ASK PROVIDERS
TO DO. I'M WORK THAT THAT THERE
ISN'T CAPACITY FOR AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO CAN. DO THE WORK WHO DO YOU
DO THE WORK M. C. PH W. YOU KNOW
FOUR THAT WAS MY FIRST JOB LAKE
THAT WAS MY FIRST PAYCHECK IN
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH. WHEN
IT WAS TO BE ABLE TO DO THOSE
ASSESSMENTS FOR PREGNANT MOMS
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEIR NEEDS
WERE MET NOT THAT I JUST
DOCUMENTED THEIR NEEDS BUT MY
JOB IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
NEEDS WERE MET. AND WE TALK
ABOUT. HERE AT HOME WELL. YOU'RE
IS IN YOUR- AND THE CARE EXISTS
THERE SO IF THERE'S A WAY FOR
YOU TO I'M- TO BUILD BACK IN AND
ALSO WITH WITH A LOT OF. TRUTH
TO DECISION MAKING ABILITY FOR
THESE AGENCIES THAT ARE TASKED
WITH THIS SO THAT WHEN SOMETHING
DOESN'T FIT IF YOU'VE GOT A
SQUARE PEG IN A ROUND HOLE THEY
HAVE PERMISSION TO CREATE US.
WHERE HOLE RIGHT SO THAT IT CAN
WORK SO THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL
YOU'VE GOT YOUR EXPERTS ALREADY
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO FIND NEW
PEOPLE TO DO THIS WORK LIKE
THEY'RE ALREADY OUT THERE IN THE
TRENCHES WE SAY WE DO IT FOR THE
OUTCOME NOT THE INCOME. MOSTLY
BECAUSE THERE'S NO INCOME- BUT
EVEN WITHOUT THAT LIKE YOU KNOW
THESE DISPARITIES DON'T CHANGE
WITH SOCIAL ECONOMIC STATUS
AMONG BLACK WOMEN- WHEN WE SAY
YOU KNOW OLD BLACK WOMAN IS TWO
OR THREE OR FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY- WHAT WE'RE AYING IS
THAT A BLACK WOMAN WITH A
COLLEGE DEGREE IS MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE A POOR OUTCOME. THAN A
CAUCASIAN WOMAN LIVING IN A
HOMELESS SHELTER IF WE. IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU HAVE TO CREATE A WAY TO
DO IT YOU JUST HAVE TO CREATE A
PATH FOR THOSE WHO ARE DOING IT
TO HAVE MORE ACCESS TO THOSE WHO
HAVE MORE NEEDS. AND NOT I AM.
NOT AN INCH. A. N. AND I KNOW
THAT'S A STRONG WORD BUT NOT
PUNISH THE FOLKS WHO ARE TRYING
VERY HARD TO FIND ALTERNATIVES
YOU KNOW IF YOU CREATE. THE
ACCESS TO MIDWIFERY CARE I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES I
WAS APPROACHED ABOUT ATTENDING
FREE BIRTH. I DON'T PRACTICE
MEDICINE I CAN'T SUPERVISOR
BIRTH MEDICALLY RIGHT BUT IF
YOU'RE SCARED TO DEATH OF GOING
TO THE HOSPITAL AND I'M SCARED
TO DEATH YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
BABY IN A MOTEL SIX. ONE OF MY
SUPPOSED TO DO RIGHT THERE HAS
TO BE A WAY TO BRIDGE. ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE ALREADY
HAPPENING AND NOT HAPPENING JUST
BE LITTLE SEGMENTED. TRENDY
TOPICS OF THE MOMENT BECAUSE
THESE ARE OUR LIVES AND WE SAVE
A MATTER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
LIVES. NOTHING ABOUT MOVEMENT
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A MOMENT
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW. EVERY DAY. ALL
DAY. OUR LIVES. THANK YOU I
THINK I REAL TALK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. MANY PEOPLE NEED TO
HEAR IT AND- RIGHT IT'S NOT A
SLOGAN AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS AND WE
NEED TO DO THE WORK AND WE NEED
TO PROVIDE IT NOW. I DO HAVE ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION WHICH HE SAID
IS THE PEOPLE ARE THERE- I KNOW
THERE ARE AMAZING INCREDIBLE
PEOPLE LIKE EVERYONE ON THIS
CALL AND EVERYONE IN THE
TRENCHES TODAY. BUT MY GUESS
WOULD BE WE NEED MORE MY GUESS
WOULD BE THAT WE DON'T HAVE. THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO PROVIDE THE
DO LESS SERVICES WE NEED IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OR AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE LOOKING TO
BUT- JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
COMMON OF YOURS. I WOULD ARGUE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS
AMONG. THE GROUPS UNTIL AS THAT
. CONSIDERED ADAM. APPROPRIATE
FOR THE WORKABLE OVER THERE
IRAQI IN TRAINING WILL BE
CATIONS ALL THESE. AND SELL ONLY
TELL YOU WERE OUT THERE WERE OUT
THERE THERE. OF OUR PEOPLE THIS
WORK ARM IN WAYS THAT MAKE SENSE
CULTURALLY FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THEY ARE SEEKING THE SUPPORT BUT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO IN REINVENT
THE WHEEL THE WHEEL IS ALREADY
THERE. THE BILL HAS ALREADY YET
BUT BUT THERE AREN'T THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN LEGISLATION THERE'S
LANGUAGE AND NEW PROGRAMS BEING
IMPLEMENTED THAT NOT ONLY
CREATES BARRIERS TO THE CLIENTS
WHO NEED THE CARE HAVING ACCESS
TO IT I PRESENTS BARRIERS FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES. AND SO THAT'S A BIG
ASK THAT THAT YOU REMOVE THOSE
THINGS- BUT TAKE CARE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY AREN'T. AND THAT
IF WE IF WE SAY HEY GUYS THIS IS
GONNA BE A PROBLEM- THAT IT BE
JUST AS VALID AS IT AS- FOR
SOMEONE WHO HAS HAS A LICENSE TO
PROVIDE MEDICINE THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE THE HEART TO PROVIDE THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE HOLISTIC CARE.
THAT THAT ARE THAT ARE. BE BACK
ARE ARE. RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD A. B.
LISTEN TO ALSO WELL AND GIVEN
JUST AS MUCH. BECAUSE YOU'RE OUT
THERE TO WORK LARA THANK YOU AND
I MEAN TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU ON THIS CALL I THINK IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL THAT AS WE CRAFT-LEGISLATION- I THINK IT'S ALWAYS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO RECOGNIZE
OUR OWN BLIND SPOTS RIGHT BE IT-
CREDIT EXPERIENCE OUR RACE OR
GENDER AND- AND IT IS CRITICAL
IN THAT PROCESS FOR EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU TO BE A VOICE TO
HELP US SEE WHAT WE DON'T SEE-
AND SO I INVITE YOU AS WE DO
THOSE THINGS TO BE IN
CONVERSATION WITH ME MY
COLLEAGUES AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
SEE THE WAY THESE IMPACTS-
LANGUAGE IMPACTS COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS. IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US UNDERSTAND YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND I KNOW NOT ALL
PERSPECTIVES HONESTLY BE THE
SAME BUT IT'S OUR JOB TO LISTEN
TO THEM AND THEN COME TO WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS IN THE INTEREST OF-
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S WOMAN. PAUL
I DO SEE AND I WAS JUST RETURN
TO MISS MOVED VERY. TURN TO ON
THIS QUESTION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- I AM THINKING ABOUT WHAT
WE CAN DO BETTER AND THE FIRST
THING I WANT TO DO IS JUST-
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS- BAKER THE CAT
MISSING READING CORRECTLY I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE A
PARTNERSHIP THAT SHE MENTIONED
THE LAST THREE BILLS THAT- BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS. ACTION
PROJECTED PASSED AND IT WAS. OUR
SUCCESS SHARED WITH YOURS AND WE
HAVE NEVER EVER EVER WE'VE NEVER
BEEN AS SUCCESSFUL AS WE HAVE
BEEN IN OUR ADVOCACY EFFORTS
UNTIL WE FOLLOWED. BLACKLICK
LEADERS. AND ORGANIZATIONS
PLACARD ORGANIZATIONS. LIKE
YOURSELVES AND SO WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL. AND IN THAT WAY. I
HEAR SO MANY THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
PEOPLE- THE SENATE BILL TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH REMOVED THE
RESTRICTION OF PHYSICIAN
PERMISSION FOR MIDWIVES TO
PRACTICE THE INTENTION THERE WAS
TO ALLOW MIDWIVES TO GO TO
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT-
MATERNITY CARE PROVIDERS AND
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT EVEN AS WE
SPEAK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON- AND JUST AS SO
MANY OTHER YOU KNOW WELL
INTENDED POLICIES DO. THIS
PARTICULAR ONE UNVEILED ANOTHER
RESTRICTION THAT EXISTS IN THAT
IS ACCESS TO PRACTICE WITHIN THE
HOSPITALS BECAUSE HOSPITALS ARE
REQUIRED TO ALLOW MIDWIVES TO
PRACTICE THERE SO WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE COUNTIES IN OUR STATE
THAT HAVE NO OBGYN PROVIDER OR
THOSE THAT ARE VERY SCARCELY-
PROVIDED WHERE WE ONLY HAVE A
FEW UNDER THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
OF PROVIDERS. WE'VE GOT MIDWIVES
WERE WILLING TO GO THERE NOW
WE'RE READY TO GO THERE NOW AND
THEY CERTAINLY COULD OPEN UP
HOME BIRTH PRACTICES THEY
CERTAINLY COULD OPEN UP
FREESTANDING BIRTH CENTERS AND
FOR A LOT OF WOMEN IN BIRTHING
PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
AND THAT WOULD BE FINE- BUT NOT
EVERYBODY WANTS AN OUT OF
HOSPITAL BIRTH NOT EVERYBODY'S A
CANDIDATE FOR IT OR SOMETIMES
EVEN WHEN IT THAT IS THE
INTENTION. THOSE WOMEN BIRTHING
PEOPLE MIGHT NEED TO OR CHOOSE
TO TRANSFER TO A HOSPITAL
SETTING FOR SOME REASON AND THE
MOST COMMON REASON FOR THOSE
TRANSFERS IS A NATURAL OR FOR
LABOR AUGMENTATION- BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS ARE WITHIN THE
INDEPENDENT SCOPE OF PRACTICE
FOR MIDWIVES BUT THERE ARE
BARRIERS TO MIDWIVES BEING ABLE
TO PRACTICE TICKET. OUT
PRIVILEGES AND HOSPITALS WITHOUT
PHYSICIAN ENDORSEMENT OR
OPPOSITION- PERMISSION SO I SEE
I SEE A NEED NOW FOR US TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN GET
MIDWIVES INTO THOSE CRITICAL
ACCESS HOSPITALS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THAT DON'T HAVE
OBGYN PROVIDER- SO THAT DON'T
HAPPEN. OR COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE- MIDWIVES WHEN THERE
ARE PEOPLE THERE WHO PREFERMENT
WITH FREE CARE. ABOUT THEM
ANOTHER THING I'M HEARING IS
MEDIC HOW. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
OUR ASSOCIATION IS WORKING ON. A
GRISLY RIGHT NOW WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO BE INVOLVED IN A
MIDWIFERY LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE- WE WERE SELECTED
AS ONE OF FIVE STATES. TO WORK
ON A PROGRAM TODAY INCREASING
ACCESS TO MIDWIFERY SERVICES
THROUGH MEDICARE ALL AND ONE OF
THE BIG PROBLEMS THAT'S COME UP
FOR US OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN ITS REIMBURSEMENT- A
SEQUESTER WAS PUT INTO PLACE I
WANT TO SAY IN TWO THOUSAND TEN-
WHERE PROVIDERS. HAD THEIR
MEDICAID REIMBURSEMENT REDUCED
BY ABOUT 10% AND THAT WAS
REVERSED FOR A POSITION
COLLEAGUES- BUT IT HASN'T BEEN
FOR MIDWIVES AND SO WHILE IT IS
HARD TO GET MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT. PERIOD THAT'S AN
ISSUE. IT'S EVEN MORE OF AN
ISSUE IF YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
MADE WITH FREE ACCESS- AND
MIDWIFERY REIMBURSEMENT BEING
REDUCED RIGHT NOW SOTHAT'S-
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ACT THEY COULD. ACT TO- INCREASE OR TO MOVE
THAT'S A QUAESTORS THAT MIDWIVES
. ARE REIMBURSED FULLY AS OUR
PHYSICIAN COLLEAGUES ARE- AND
THERE BUT THERE WILL. AND HEREBY
INCREASE ACCESS TO MIDWIFERY
CARE FOR MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE-
BIRTHING PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE OTHER THING I'M HEARING IS-
INCREASING OUR WORKFORCE RIGHT-
AND HAVING CULTURALLY CONGRUENT
. I CARE PROVIDERS I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT- SO GRATEFUL
FOR THE MOM THE BEST AND- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT. THAT BILL
DID WAS CREATE A MIDWIFERY
WORKFORCE TRAINING FUNDS- AND
THAT WOULD BE SPECIFICALLY
GEARED TOWARD BRINGING MIDWIVES
TO COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
ENHANCE. ALSO. BRINGING IN
MIDWIVES OF COLOR TO READ OVER
SUPPLY THE MIDWIFERY WORKFORCE
IN OUR STATE AND WE SAY READ A
VERSIFI ANYTHING THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT THING TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT- ADDITIONALLY IF YOU GO
BACK A FEW HUNDRED YEARS.
MIDWIFERY BELONG TO ALL OF THE
PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY
EVERY SINGLE CONTINENT HAD ITS
OWN MIDWIVES- AND IT WASN'T
UNTIL. THROUGH THE PROCESS
VARIOUS PROCESS SEES A
CONVERSATION- THAT MIDWIFERY WAS
ELIMINATED AND THEN IT WAS
BROUGHT BACK BUT ONLY WHITE AND
SO NOW WE NEED TO TAKE THINGS
BACK TO OUR ANCESTORS AND TO THE
PEOPLE WHO STARTED IT HERE IN
THE SPACE SO. AGAIN GRATITUDE
FOR SB SIXTY FIVE HOPING TO SEE
MORE DONE AND MY FRIENDS- AND
AGAIN HOPING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO BREAK DOWN THE BARRIERS. THAT
WE CAN GET MIDWIVES TO THIS
CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITALS. IN
THOSE COUNTIES THAT NEED THEM
AND- GET ADEQUATE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR MIDWIVES WHO WANT TO ACCEPT
MEDIC HELEN PROVIDE CARE TO
THOSE PEOPLE. WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THOSE SERVICES. THANK YOU I
AM AND I THINK THAT WE'VE
TOUCHED ON A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT WHICH IS YOU KNOW
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CARE RIGHT
ENSURING THAT OUR- CARE
PROVIDERS ARE- AND THE COMMUNITY
THEY SERVE FRIE ENSURING THAT
WE ARE SUPPORTING THAT AND NOT
BLOCKING IT AND BY ANY MEANS- SO
THANK YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING THAT
ENDS AND THE IMPORTANT STUFF WE
STILL HAVE TO GO I. HAD TO BE
HONEST THAT WHEN SENATOR SKINNER
INTRODUCED THE MOM OF A SPELL I
THOUGHT THIS IS INCREDIBLE AND
IT MAY TAKE THE REST OF HER
TENURE TO GET IT PASSED SO THE
FACT THAT. ONE YEAR WAS REALLY.
INCREDIBLE FICO M. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR ADVOCACY ON THAT
BECAUSE I REALLY DO HOPE. THAT
IT CHANGES A LOT OF THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA AND- I THINK- IT IS
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE ARE
SHOWING. THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
LEAD THE NATIONAND HOPEFULLY WE
WILL SEE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FOLLOW OUR LEAD. AND PROVIDE
THIS CARE FOR WOMEN ACROSS THE
NATION. AS SO- WITH THAT I WANT
TO. ASK- I'M A CLOSING QUESTION
- AND I INVITE YOU ANSWERING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO REALLY TELL
THE STORIES OF THE WOMEN THAT
YOU SERVE I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THEIR VOICES TO BE
HERE WITH US TODAY- BUT I JUST
WONDER WHAT WAYS DURING THE
PANDEMIC HAS THE GOVERNMENT'S
STOOD IN THE WAY OF ACCESS TO
CARE I KNOW THAT TO ME A COUPLE
THINGS THAT COME TO MIND WAS THE
RULES THAT PREVENTED AND
PREGNANT PEOPLE FROM HAVING A
PARTNER OR A DO THAT IN THE
ROOM. HI DURING CHILDBIRTH WHICH
WOULD HAVE TO SAY AGAIN HAVING
BEEN A BIRTHING PERSON I CANNOT
IMAGINE BEING ALONE IN THAT
MOMENT I'M BEING TO ADDICT ABLE
TO ADEQUATELY ADVOCATE FOR
MYSELF- SO OBVIOUSLY THAT COMES
TO MIND BUT I ALSO WONDER
COMMUNICATIONS YOU KNOW WHAT WAS
MENTIONED IN THE PRIOR PANEL AND
HAS BEEN TOUCHED UPON I'M HERE
IS- REALLY THEY NEED TO BUILD
TRUST BETWEEN THOSE WHO THAT ARE
IN NEED OF CARE WHO ARE
ACCESSING CARE AND PROVIDERS AND
I THE COMMUNICATIONS- FROM THE
GOVERNMENTS HOPING DURING THE
PANDEMIC. I WONDER HOW THEY HAVE
AFFECTED- YOU KNOW CARE AND THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE CARE
SO I JUST REALLY IF- I DON'T
KNOW WHO WANTS TO START WITH
THAT MAYBE I MISSED YOUR IDEA IF
YOU WANT TO LEAD THE
CONVERSATION ON THAT BUT I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO KNOW WHAT WE HAVE
DONE. THE GOVERNMENT. I'M WELL.
IT'S ALSO TO. SOLD THE
GUIDELINES. AT NECESSARILY I GAS
HAVE FALLEN SHORT WITH THE
SPORADIC AND DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH YOU KNOW
GRACIOUSLY BEGIN KNOWLEDGE NONE
OF THIS IS NEVER BEEN THROUGH
THIS BEFORE NONE OF US HAVE DONE
AB HE A PANDEMIC BEFORE IT NOT
POLICYMAKERS AND NOT THE SCIENCE
THEY RELY ON. AND IT CAN'T
HAPPEN FASTER THAN THIS. THEIR
VIRUS. ADAM HAS REAL LIFE
IMPACTED BUT FOR ME THAT THE
FAILURE IS WHERE IT POLICIES
CHANGE MIDSTREAM- EVEN I'VE I'VE
BEEN AT A BIRTH FOR THE POLICY
CHANGED WHILE I WAS THERE LIKE
THAT THE REQUIREMENT FOR. BEING
WITH THAT FAMILY CHANGED A LOT I
WAS THERE- AND SO OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. WE DO OUR PART WE HAVE A
FAMILY CALL BEFORE YOU GET THERE
AND ASK WHAT THE POLICIES ARE
FOR VISITORS CALL WHEN YOU'RE
LABOR STARTS TO ASK WHAT THE
POLICY IS ASK THEM WHEN YOU GET
THERE ASK THEM WHEN YOU HAVE THE
BABY AND- AS OFTEN AS NOT. IT'S
A DIFFERENT ANSWER EVERY TIME-
AND THAT'S NOT JUST GOVERNING
BODIES POLICIES THAT
ADMINISTRATION OF HOSPITALS
THAT'S YOU KNOW SUBJECTIVE AND
OBJECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION-
DEPENDING ON THE MOOD OF
APHORISMS SHIFT AT THE TIME. AND
EVERYBODY IS OVERWHELMED. AND
THAT OVERWHELM IS VALID FOR
EVERYBODY BUT NOT EVERYBODY IS
TRYING TO GET A HOLD OF HIM AND
BEING OUT OF THEIR BODY IN THE
MIDST OF IT AND SO I THINK THAT.
THAT AND- ABOUT LACK OF REVIEWS
ON THE ONE HAND TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT WHAT WORKS FOR YOU AS
A PERSON WE TALK ABOUT AUTONOMY
WE TALK ABOUT BEING ABLE
ADVOCATE FOR OUR OWN BODIES. AND
THAT SHOULD INCLUDE. YOUR BIRTH
TEAMS RIGHT I MEAN I SHOULD BE
AT THE TOWARD THE TOP OF THE
LIST TUESDAY WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
HAVE. YOUR BABY AND IT JUST IT
BEATS THE TRAUMA THAT ALREADY
THERE BECAUSE THEY ARE WOMEN ARE
ALREADY AFRAID LIKE WHEN I
STARTED. BEING A DELAY EVEN IN
TWENTY NINETEEN BEING A DOULA
WHEN I INTERVIEWED APPLYING IT
YOU KNOW AND I SAY WHAT MAKES
YOU WANT THE SERVICE. AND THEY
WOULD HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS YOU
EXPECT I WANT TO NATURAL BIRTH
OR I WANT SOMEBODY THERE WHO
CAN. GIVE ME MY OPTIONS OR I
WANNA MAKE GOOD DECISIONS OR I
WANT SOMEONE TO HELP MY PARTNER
HELPED ME HAVE THIS BABY. AND
THIS YEAR LAST YEAR THE ANSWER
WAS I JUST DON'T WANT TO DIE.
THAT WAS STOPPING HEART. WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THIS THIS
THIS THING IN THE SHIFTING
POLICIES TAKE AWAY THE MAGIC OF
THOSE INITIAL MOMENTS WHEN MOMS
ARE AFRAID TO TAKE A CO THAT
TEST NOT BECAUSE THEY THINK
THEY'RE SICK BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE
AFRAID IF IT HAPPENS TO TURN UP
POP POSITIVE DOES THAT MEAN I'M
GOING TO BE SEPARATED FROM MY
BABY DOES THIS MEAN I GET TO
BREAST FEED MY BABY DOES THIS
MEAN SOMEBODY'S GOING TO CALL
THE PEOPLE ON ME IF I DECLINE
THIS TEST BECAUSE I WANT TO STAY
WITH MY BABY. WHAT IS THAT THAT
LOOKED LIKE AND SO ANY TIME YOU
SPENT MONTHS AND MONTHS WORKING
WITH A FAMILY AND GUIDING THEM
THROUGH PLANNING THEIR LABOR AND
DELIVERY AND THE POSTPARTUM
BONDING TO SEE THAT BE SNATCHED
AWAY M. IT'S HEARTBREAKING WHEN
THERE ISN'T A RECOURSE AND FOR
ME NOT BEING ABLE TO BE WITH
THEM NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE AN
ADJUSTMENT. S. S. OR OR RESPONSE
IN REAL TIME TO HAVE TO ADJUST
TO BURCHELL SUPPORT I MEAN HOW
HARD IS IT TO TALK TO SOMEBODY
THROUGH A MASK RIGHT SO YOU'RE
TALKING THROUGH THE MASCULINE
MATCHING AMASSED WE'RE TRYING TO
DO BREATHING TECHNIQUES I CAN'T
SEE HER FACE FULLY I CERTAINLY
CAN'T SEE HER FACE FULLY THROUGH
A MASK AM ON FACETIME. ON VIDEO
RIGHT SO THERE'S ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT THAT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT YOU KNOW LIKE SOMEBODY AT.
THE TOP DECIDING WHAT STATE. AND
YOU COMPARE THAT TO SOME. WHO
DOWN HERE IN IT IN THE TRENCHES
. AND TRYING TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
WHAT IS. IT'S DIFFICULT WHEN
THERE'S NOT THAT FLEXIBILITY M.
IT IT IT CAN BE CATASTROPHIC TO
A FAMILY THAT MAY BE. RADULA
ALREADY. AND WE'RE COMING INTO A
SITUATION AND YOU'VE GOT A MOM
WHO'S ALREADY AFRAID TO HAVE A
BABY IN A PANDEMIC IN A HOSPITAL
IN BLACK SKIN. AND THEN SHE HAS
TO TELL HER BABY'S FATHER HE
CAN'T BE THERE SHE HAS TO TELL
HER MOTHER SHE CAN'T BE THERE
FOR HER BEST FRIEND OR HURDLE
THAT LIKE. ALL OF THESE THINGS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN BREATHING ON HER THE ENTIRE
TIME. SO THERE'S NOT THIS HUGE
INCREASED RISK OF HAVING THEM BE
BY HER. STILL AGAIN RIGHT LIKE
NOTHING HAS CHANGED WITH THAT
AND I THINK THAT THAT. FOR ALL
OF THE GOOD INTENTION THAT THERE
ARE FOR THE GUIDELINES- AND THEY
MAKE SENSE BIG PICTURE THEY
REALLY REALLY DO I DON'T WANT TO
BE ON A BUS WITH ANYBODY WITHOUT
A MASK I DON'T WANT TO BE ON A
PLANE WITH ANYBODY WITHOUT A
MASK AND VACCINES AND ALL THAT
THAT MAKES SENSE BUT IN OUR
LITTLE SMALL CIRCLE FAMILY.
BUBBLES OF BIRTH. THERE HAS TO
BE THAT BAD LIKE STABILITY AND I
. THE OTHER PART AND THIS IS THE
HARD PART OF THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT ALL THE
STATISTICS FOR THE PART THAT
COMES WE KNOW THAT IT'S NOT A
QUESTION WE'VE GOT ALL OF THE
STATISTICS SO FAR OF HOW THIS
THE PANDEMIC AFFECTS PEOPLE AND
IMPACTS PEOPLE BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
IS THE MAGNIFYING. THAT A
PANDEMIC HAS PLACED ON BIASES.
THE INCREASE THE ENERGY THE
POWER THAT THEY HAVE BEEN GIVEN
WHERE. AN INDIVIDUAL'S BIAS CAN
TAKE AWAY AN ENTIRE BIRTH PLAN
AND THERE'S NO RECOURSE AND WHEN
THERE IS A LACK OF. SHARED%
VALUES FROM THE PEOPLE AT THE
TOP WHO WON ALL THE BEST FOR
EVERYBODY AND THE FOLKS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE HANDS ON
CARE- THAT CAUSES DRAMATIC BIRTH
EXPERIENCES. FOR WORKING
FAMILIES I. HAD. ANDERSON
MINISTRY- WALK INTO A ROOM. WITH
ANOTHER ADMINISTRATOR WHO WAS
NOT A CARE PROVIDER JUST
SOMEBODY WHO WAS PURELY
ADMINISTRATION BE BROUGHT INTO A
ROOM WHEN A FATHER REQUESTED TO
AT. ASK QUESTIONS AND THEN FILE
AT A REPORT OR A GRIEVANCE WHEN
THE FAMILIES BIRTH PLAN WAS NOT
FILED. AND EIGHT. THAT POLICY
THAT POPPED UP ALL OF A SUDDEN.
I'D SAY THAT WASN'T LEGITIMATE
BUT IT ONLY CAME UP AFTER THE
BABY WAS BORN WAS THAT THEY
DISCARDED ME THE DILEMMA FROM
THE BIRTH UNTIL THEY SAID THEY
SAID THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR MONTHS
CO THAT TEST TO COME BACK. I HAD
BEEN IN THE HOSPITAL REPEATEDLY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC THAT HAVE
NEVER COME UP IT DIDN'T COME UP
UNTIL AFTER HE SAID. WHY WASN'T
HARD LEFT ABLE TO COME IN AND BE
WITH US FIRST TIME COUPLE FIRST
TIME PARENTS ALL OF THIS HE WAS
NEVER ANYTHING OTHER THAN.
BUSINESS WHO CAN I TALK TO.
ADOLESCENT MINISTRY TO CAYMAN.
AND SHE STARTED TOUCHING MY
CLIENTS FACE RUBBING HER FACE
AND SHE WAS LIKE HOME WE'VE
TAKEN SUCH GOOD CARE OF YOU HAVE
AT LEAST YOU HAVE SUCH A GOOD
EXPERIENCE HERE BUT- I'M FEELING
THREATENED AND I'VE ALREADY
CALLED SECURITY AND SO. IF HE
KEEPS GOING THEN I'M JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO M. AND LITERALLY THIS
MOM WHO STILL DRIPPING FROM
BIRTHING HER SON. IS HAVING TO
HAVE HER ONE ADVOCATE THAT COULD
BE THEY'RE- NOT DO HIS JOB. AND
IT WAS THE MOST. SICKENING THING
THAT I HAVE EVER SEEN. M. AND
THOSE ARE THE REAL STORIES
ANOTHER MOM SINGLE MOM DOING
WHAT YOU SUPPOSED TO DO SHOWING
UP FOR AN EMERGENCY ULTRASOUND
BECAUSE SOMETHING WASN'T RIGHT
IN THIS PREGNANCY AND WHEN SHE
GETS TO THE PLACE THEY TURNED
AWAY BECAUSE OF COLLUDED
PROTOCOLS SHE CAN'T GO ON WITH
THEIR KIDS. SO SHE STANDING
OUTSIDE AND WE'RE CALLING
EVERYBODY UNDER THE SUN TRYING
TO FIND SOMEBODY WHO CAN GET TO
HER WITHIN TWENTY MINUTES DURING
PEAK HOUR TRAFFIC SO THAT SHE
CAN GO IN AND GET HER TESTING
DONE WE FOUND SOMEBODY THIS
PERSON STATE OUT STOOD OUTSIDE
WITH HER CHILDREN SHE GOES IN
FROM THAT EXAM THEY SENT HER TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM. CAN YOU
IMAGINE. IF SHE HADN'T HAD THIS
EXTENDED COMMUNITY TO TRY TO
FIND SOMEBODY TO BE WITH HER
KIDS AND THE REALITY IS. A LOT
OF MAMAS. HAVE KIT. AND A LOT OF
APPOINTMENTS ARE MISSED BECAUSE
- COVERT DOESN'T MAKE PROVISION
FOR. THE POLICIES. DON'T MAKE
PROVISION FOR THAT AND STILL. I. I KNOW THAT EVERY STORY IS
DIFFERENT. I KNOW THAT EVERY
BODY HAS THEIR THEIR VALUES AND
THEIR EXPERIENCES AND THEY'RE
ALL. EQUALLY VALID. BUT IF OUR
JOB IS TO PROTECT THOSE WHO ARE
MOST VULNERABLE WE HAVE TO START
THERE WE HAVE TO START WITH WITH
THOSE EXPERIENCES AND THOSE
VOICES BEING PRIORITIES WE HAVE
TO START WITH. FILTERING WHETHER
THE NEW THINGS THAT COME OUT TO
DO WORK FOR THOSE FAMILIES AND
IF THEY DON'T WE'VE GOT TO DO A
DEAD STOP AND FIX IT BEFORE WE
MOVE FORWARD AND THAT WOULD BE
MY ASK AND IF YOU EVER WANT A
SECOND SET OF BLACK THAT A
HUNDRED LIVES AND PUT MY NUMBER
IN THE CHAT LIKE FOLLOW ME. I'M. HERE I'M AVAILABLE AND- I'M
WILLING. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF A
STRATEGY FOR. SCHERING NOW IT
HAS IT WAS INCREDIBLY POWERFUL
AND I THINK WHAT IT REALLY
RAISES IS THAT TO YOUR POINT
THAT YOU MADE THAT THERE. THE
POLICIES WHICH ARE THERE TO
PROTECT LIVES IN IN MANY
CONTEXTS MAKES SENSE ON AN
AIRPLANE IN A BUS- I THINK WHAT
YOU ARE HIGHLIGHTING AND WHEN
NEEDS TO NEVER BE FORGOTTEN IS
THAT IF WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO
IS PROTECT THE LIVES AND
WELLBEING. OF THESE VULNERABLE
PEOPLE HE'S COVERED POLICY
YOU'RE DOING EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE RIGHT BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE DATA BEARS OUT AND THE
STORIES CARE OUT THE YOU BEING
IN THE RUMORED TO LIVING IN
THURMOND ADVOCATING OR-
DECREASES THE RISK. OF MORTALITY
FOR WOMEN OF COLOR AND SO IF WE
ARE HERE TO PROTECT THEIR LIVES
THAT HAS TO BE A PART OF THE
CALCULATION. AND THE SAFETY OF
THOSE CHILDREN THERE WERE
STANDING UTSIDE THE CLINIC AND
YOU KNOW THE SAFETY GOES BEYOND
JUST THAT OF KOBE NINETEEN AND
IT OBVIOUSLY NEEDS TO BE TOP OF
MIND AND HAS TAKEN. MORE LIVES
THAN ANY OF US WOULD HAVE LIKED
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW
AS WE HEARD FROM MR- I KIA
SERVICE CHILDBIRTH. RIGHT AND SO
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
BALANCING ALL THE NEEDS AND THE
VOICES YOU BRING TO THIS
CONVERSATION ARE REALLY CRITICAL
SO THANK YOU- I KNOW THAT THIS
IS ONLY THE BEGINNING OF A
CONVERSATION FOR US- OF HOW WE
CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT-
BRINGING PEOPLE THROUGH WHAT IS.
SHOULD BE THE MOST INCREDIBLE
EXPERIENCE OF THEIR LIVES BUT
ISN'T ALWAYS THAT AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE. WE GET THERE- READ.
THE RISKS AND INCREASING THE JOY
IN THOSE MOMENTS SO. THANK YOU
FOR BEING DOING THE WORK EVERY
DAY BEING IN THE TRENCHES AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
PARTNERSHIPS AND HOW WE AS-
LAWMAKERS AND POLICYMAKERS CAN
SUPPORT THE WORK YOU DO. THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU- AND WE
ARE. OVER TIME BECAUSE THAT
CONVERSATION WAS SO GOOD SO I'M
GOING TO. STICK AND ALL THANK
YOU ALL- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
A PANEL THREE WHICH WILL BE
FOCUSED ON DOMESTIC AND GENDER
BASED VIOLENCE. AND- WE PROBABLY
WILL GO OVER BY ABOUT TWENTY
MINUTES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THE CLOCK AND- SO WE
REALLY WANTED TO WORK THIS INTO
OUR PANEL BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT-
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- IS
PARTICULARLY. PACKED FULL ON.
AND WOMEN IN WOMEN DURING THEIR
REPRODUCTIVE YEARS MATERNAL
HEALTH THE WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
KNOW THAT. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WAS
UNDER RESOURCED PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND THE STRESSES THE
FINANCIAL STRAINS AND HOUSING
INSECURITY OF THIS PANDEMIC ONLY
COMPLICATED THE ISSUE AND
EXACERBATED AT. SO TODAY WE'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM EXPERTS AND
ADVOCATES WORKING WITH SURVIVORS
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE PANDEMIC
IMPACTED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
WHAT POLICY RESPONSES ARE NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS ARE
ADEQUATELY PROTECTED GOING
FORWARD. SO ON THIS PANEL WE
HAVE NO THE L. MORRIS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MY SISTER'S HOUSE
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO ALISON
MESSENGER MANAGING STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE GENESSEE CENTER
AND KRISTA COLOGNE PUBLIC POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE PARTNERSHIP TO
END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND SO WE
WILL START AGAIN WITH THE
INTRODUCTIONS- IN TELLING US A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR WORK AND
HOW THE WORK IS GENERALLY CHANGE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND WE WILL
OPEN WITH NO THAT. THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS NOT ABOUT MARS AND I'VE
BEEN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
MY SISTER'S HOUSE FOR THE PAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS. AS YOU SHARED
Y SISTER'S HOUSE IS A NONPROFIT
BASED IN SACRAMENTO PROVIDING
SHELTER AND SERVICES TO VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WHAT MAKES OUR ORGANIZATION
SPECIAL AND UNIQUE ARE TWO
TRAITS ONE OUR CULTURAL
RESPONSIVE EXPERTISE DEALING
WITH ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
VICTIMS. AND TO OUR EXPERTISE IS
THE ONLY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTER IN CALIFORNIA PERHAPS IN
THE NATION. THAT OPERATES A CAFE
WHICH PROVIDES JOB TRAINING AND
INCOME FOR OUR SURVIVORS. AND
RECENTLY WE OPENED UP A GIVE
STARTER STORE WE HAVE A STAFF OF
TWENTY OF WHICH SOME ARE
SURVIVORS RECEIVING JOB TRAINING
SKILLS AND EXPERIENCE. IN
ADDITION TO BEING A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MY SISTER'S
HOUSE IS ALSO A MEMBER AND
FOUNDER OF THE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NETWORK. OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE
ARTY BEGAN WHICH IS A
COLLABORATION OF SEVENTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA REFLECTING. ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LATIN NEXT
BLACKED EXACTLY CHALLENGED AND
L. G. B. T. Q. I. H. MOVIES
WHICH IS BEEN SUPPORTED. WITH
BLUE SHIELD FOUNDATION. OUR
CULTURE IS ONE OF THE MOST
VIOLENCE BUT WE- THAT TO. A
GENDER BASED FILE IN CALIFORNIA
WE NEED TO BUILD AND STRENGTHEN
OUR CULTURE RESPONSIBLE
ORGANIZATIONS WHICH FOCUS ON OUR
UNDERSERVED IN CHALLENGE
COMMUNITIES. COVERT NINETEEN IS
DRAMATIZED THE WEAKNESSES OF
LAWS ALREADY IN OUR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SYSTEM. TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY SERVE CALIFORNIANS
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I
URGE THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND
ITS MEMBERS TO TAKE ACTIONS TO
ACCOMPLISH THE FOLLOWING. INSURE
THAT WHEN YOU CREATE FUNDED
PROGRAMS THAT THERE IS A FUNDING
SET ASIDE FOR THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
EXPERTISE IN DEALING WITH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH LANGUAGE
AND CULTURAL ISSUES. AND SECOND
TO ENSURE THAT ALL EXISTING
FUNDING PROGRAMS UNDER YOUR
PURVIEW MAKE MEASURABLE PROGRESS
TOWARDS SERVING ALL OF THEIR
COMMUNITY- AND I. WILL ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS LATER THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER THOMAS NOW WILL
TURN IT OVER TO MISS MESSENGER
INTERACTION. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ALLISON MESSENGER AND I
HAD THE DISTINCT PLEASURE BEING
THE MANAGING STAFF ATTORNEY AT
GENESEE CENTER. JEALOUSY CENTER
IS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM BASED IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES OUR SERVICE AREA IS A
SERVICE POPULATION AREA SIX L.
A. COUNTY. SENATE THE CENTER WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN WHO
ARE SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND WE DO APPROACH TO
WORK WITH THE CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC LANDS. TOWARDS BLACK
AND AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN.
JENNY THE CENTER STARTED VERY
VERY GRASS ROOTS WITH JUST A
HOTLINE THAT OFFERED THINGS LIKE
FOOD BASKET. DIAPERS BABY
FORMULA AND CLOSE TO WOMEN AND
<c.green>HILDREN FLEEING DOMESTIC</c>
VIOLENCE. QUICKLY THE NEED FOR
SHELTER WAS RECOGNIZED WE OPENED
OUR FIRST EMERGENCY SHELTER
THREE YEARS AFTER WE WERE FOUND
IT. AND FROM THESE VERY VERY
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS CHEN IS THE
CENTER HAS GROWN TO BECOME A
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED PROGRAM. CURRENTLY WE
OFFER EMERGENCY AND TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAMS AS WELL AS A
HOST OF COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES
INCLUDING CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS PROGRAMS DIRECTLY GO
SERVICES. AND CASE MANAGEMENT
WHICH ARE PROBABLY ALREADY SAID-
AND MANY MANY OTHER SERVICES
INCLUDING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. OUR WORK HAS CHANGED
QUITE DRASTICALLY IN THE WAKE OF
COBIT MOST NOTICEABLY IT IS
CHANGED IN THE WAY THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO SHELTER FAMILIES IN NEED
OF EMERGENCY HOUSING. MOST
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTER
PROGRAMS OPERATE ON THE COMMUNAL
HOUSING MODEL. BUT AS SOON AS
THE STAY AT HOME ORDERS WERE
IMPOSED WE RECOGNIZE THAT
COMMUNAL LIVING NO LONGER FELT
SAFE. OR CLIENTS OR FOR OUR
STAFF. AND IN THE INITIAL DAYS
OF TE PANDEMIC WE WERE ABLE TO
PARTNER WITH OUR LOCAL CITY
GOVERNMENTS IN A PROGRAM CALLED.
PROJECT SAFE HAVEN WHICH ALLOWED
US TO HOUSE FAMILIES IN A HOTEL.
WE WERE ALLOCATED NINETY HOTEL
ROOMS AND IN THE NINE MONTHS
PROJECT SAFE HAVEN WAS
OPERATIONAL. OUR OUR ROOMS WERE
NEVER VACANT TO GIVE YOU A
SNAPSHOT OF HOW COLD IT AFFECTED
THE NEED FOR SHELTER ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THAT MANY OTHER ESCAPE
ROUTES SUCH AS STAYING WITH
FAMILY FRIENDS OBTAINING A
RESTRAINING ORDER OR EVEN JUST
GOING TO THE POLICE AND ASKING
FOR HELP WERE IMPACTED BY. THE
PANDEMIC THE NEED FOR SHELTER
GREATLY EXPANDED. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN HOUSED TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN NEW FAMILIES
WHO WERE IN NEED OF EMERGENCY
SHELTER. IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT
NUMBER EXPLODED. TWO FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIVE WHICH
REPRESENTS. 86% INCREASE. NOW
SINCE FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS LIKE
PROJECTS STATE CAPE AND HAVE
GONE AWAY AND WE ARE NO LONGER
ABLE TO MAKE AVAILABLE THE
QUANTITY OF HOTEL ROOMS THAT WE
HAD DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC TO DATE WE HAVE HOUSE A
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE FAMILIES
IN OUR LAREST SHELTERS WHICH
REPRESENTS A 63% DECREASE FROM
TWENTY TWENTY AND 31% DECREASE
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN.
SO FOR US THIS OBVIOUSLY RAISES
CONCERNS THAT WE ARE NOT SERVING
THE NEEDS OF. VICTIMS WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF EMERGENCY
SHELTER AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS
WE URGENTLY ASK ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IS TO
CREATE FUNDING THAT IS NOT TIED
TO METRICS THAT NO LONGER MAKES
SENSE IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC SUCH AS BAD NIGHTS.
WERE HEAD COUNTS ST BINDING THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO BE MORE
FLEXIBLE AND HOW WE HOUSING
INDIVIDUALS IN IMMEDIATE NEED OF
EMERGENCY SHELTER. AND WITH THAT
I WILL CONCLUDE MY OPENING
REMARKS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MATH MATH CENTER
AND NOW- MISS COLOGNE WHO IS NO
STRANGER HERE IN THE CAPITAL OF
TURNED OVER TO YOU TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. WHAT ACTUALLY
LEVY TO GIVE US A LITTLE BIT OF
LEVELLAND PRIOR TO PANDEMIC AND
HOW IT CHANGED DURING THE PAST.
THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THOUGHT
MY NAME IS. KRISTA COLOGNE AND
THE POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WE ARE THE
STATEWIDE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ORGANIZATION. AND THAT MEANS
THAT I HAVE THE TREMENDOUS
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH FOLKS
LIKE ALLISON AND NELDA AND THEIR
COLLEAGUES ALL ACROSS THE STATE
EVERY DAY. OUR ROLE AS AN
ORGANIZATION BROADLY SPEAKING
INSISTS. HELP BRING THE ISSUES
IMPACTING THE SURVIVORS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO THE
CAPITAL. TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
TO LOCAL PROGRAMS TO HELP THEM
TO PROVIDE THE BEST POSSIBLE
SERVICES. UNTIL BEYONCE
PROFESSION PREVENTION AFTER. WE
BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS NOT INEVITABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. SO A LOT OF OUR
WORK IS FOCUSED ON. HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT AND. FURTHER ATTENTION.
BUT A START WITH YOUR A BIT OF A
- LINE OF HOW. DOMESTIC FOUND
LOOKED IN CALIFORNIA PANDEMIC
AND WHAT WE SEE YES- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONDED TO OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALL. IN A
CITY NEAR NEARLY 9% OF ALL
MUSLIMS IN THE STATE WERE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RELATED WITH
THE NINETY INDIVIDUALS LOSING
THEIR LIVES. SIXTY EIGHT OF WERE
THAT PEOPLE TWENTY TWO ROOM. AND
FIVE OF THOSE WHO WEREKILLED
THE NIGHT YEAR RICH CHILDREN-
INCLUDING MARTIN UNDER THE AGE
OF FIVE. TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
SERVICE AND- IN FISCAL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. HUNDRED INTO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTER
PROGRAMS HERE IN THE STATE.
ANSWERED ALMOST EIGHTY THOUSAND
HOTLINE CALLS. PROVIDED NEARLY
NINETEEN THOUSAND SURVIVORS AND
CHILDREN WITH EMERGENCY. SHELTER
TOTAL OF SIX HUNDRED AND.
450-008-0060 THREE THAT NIGHT.
TO PUT THOSE RATHER STAGGERING
NUMBERS PER YEAR AND CISCO I'M
JUST ONE DAY IN. TWENTY NINETEEN
FIVE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR SURVIVORS AND
CHILDREN WERE SICKENED BY
DOMESTIC OUT. OF INCLUDING THREE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
ADULT AND CHILD VICTIMS WHO
CONCEIVED HOUSING SERVICES.
ANOTHER TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
RECEIVED NOT RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES THAT INCLUDE COUNSELING
LEGAL ADVOCACY CHILDREN'S GROUPS
AND MUCH MORE. DESPITE ALL OF
THAT WORK ALL OF THE NEED THAT
WAS IN THAT IN THAT ONE DAY THAT
SAME DAY. OVER TWELVE HUNDRED
REQUESTS FOR SERVICES WENT UNMET
DUE TO THE LACK OF RESEARCH THAN
OF WHICH ABOUT 51% OR SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY REFER HOUSING
AND EMERGENCY SHELTER. AND
THAT'S WHAT THE SITUATION WAS
BEFORE THAT HAPPENS. WHEN CO
THAT HAPPENED AND AS YOU'VE
HEARD ALISON AND BUILD THE
RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS HAVE HAD TO
ADAPT DRAMATICALLY. INTO HOW
THEY RESPOND. I WHAT WE KNOW
THAT THE NEED FOR. THAT CHU.
RESEARCH BEEN- A MERGING OF THAT
. THE INCREASED NEED. WE'VE SEEN
. DATA FROM BOTH ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES AND
INTERNATIONALLY ABOUT INCREASED
RATES OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WE
HEARD FROM PROGRAMS ABOUT HOW
LINE'S RINGING OFF THE HOOK. AND
WE'VE ALSO HEARD A CHANCE THAT I
THINK IS IMPORTANT THE NAME.
ARTICULAR AS WE HOPEFULLY WE SEE
SOME LIGHT AT THE END OF A COLD
AND TUMBLE. WHICH IS THE- MANY
TIMES WHEN WE WOULD SEE DEATHS
IN CASE FRIDAY WHEN RESTRICTIONS
WOULD START TO. BE REDUCED
RENDON PEOPLE FELT MORE
COMFORTABLE BEING OUT IN
SOCIETY. THAT'S ONE PROGRAMS SAW
A LARGE SPIKES IN THE RATE OF
SURVIVORS FILE THAT THERE WOULD
SAFETY AND BEING ABLE TO THINK
ABOUT LEAVING THEIR HOME CHÁVEZ
AN UNSAFE SITUATION BANKING
ABOUT REACHING OUT FOR HELP.
THOSE INCREASES A MERGED EVEN US
COPE AND DECLINING AND OF COURSE
THE THIS PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN
ABSENT CLOSE. WE KNOW THE HAD NO
POINT HAS IT EVER BEEN SLOWER
QUIET OR PROGRAM. AND I WILL
JUST LEAVE IT BUT THE OTHER
TEAMS THAT IT. TO BE MINDFUL OF
AS CO THAT HAS INVOLVED IS THAT
THE WAY PROGRAMS MEET THE NEEDS
SURVIVORS OF THE BALL. ALISON
SPOKE ABOUT OXYGEN TO THEIR
HOUSING PROGRAMS ALSO
ADAPTATIONS TO HOW WE SUPPORT
SURVIVORS AND NAVIGATING THE
COURT SYSTEM HOW ARE COURTS ARE
EVEN OPEN OR ACCEPTING REQUESTS
FOR RESTRAINING ORDERS. BACKLOGS
AND HEARING THOSE. ALL SORTS OF
CORD. WE'VE SEEN A RISE IN USE
OF TELEHEALTH OR REMOTE YOU KNOW
IN ZOOM BASED OR OTHER MORE
SECURE- VIDEO AND VIRTUAL
PLATFORMS TO PROVIDE COUNSELING
AND PEER SUPPORT GROUPS- BOTH
WITH VERY POSITIVE RESULTS AND
WE THINK ABOUT COMMUNITY IS
WHERE TRANSPORTATION CAN BE A
REAL BARRIER RIGHT THIS HAS
REDUCED TRANSPORTATION CAN
CHALLENGES. AND ALSO WE IS AND
WHICH THIS IS THAN A LESS THAN
IDEAL SITUATION TECHNOLOGY ISN'T
PERFECT AS WE ALL KNOW THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN OUR COMMUNITY
IS VERY REAL AND CERTAINLY NOT
EVERY SURVIVOR HAS ACCESS TO
THOSE SAFETY AND PRIVACY IN
THEIR OWN HOME TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE TYPES OF SEARCH
ENGINE IN. THE- IN TERMS OF WHAT
THINGS LOOK LIKE NOW I THINK IN
SOME WAYS THE CONSTANT AND OTHER
PROGRAMS HAVE NEVER CLOSE
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE NEVER
STOPPED ME THIS NEED AND THE
NEED CONTINUES TO BE. A MORE
INTENSE. THE CHALLENGES IN
HELPING SURVIVOR NAVIGATE TO
SAFETY REAL. AND I'LL HAVE TURN
HAVE TO KNOW THAT ISLANDS AND TO
SHARE MORE ABOUT THOSE IN. THANK
YOU MESCALERO NINE I. OUR YOU
SPOKE A THE NEED FOR US TO FIND
HOUSING IN A FLEXIBLE WAY- BUT
I'M WONDERING IF EITHER OF YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS MISS COLLINS-
POINT ABOUT WHAT OTHER NEEDS YOU
LIKE US TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
FOCUS ON MOVING FORWARD. AND I
GUESS ARGUE NOW THAT HE'S LIKE.
IT THANK YOU I'VE I THINK THAT'S
IF THERE ARE WAYS TO ADDRESS
RACISM I KNOW THAT THAT THAT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT BUT THAT THERE
HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIAL RACISM
ESPECIALLY THAT OUR CLIENTS HAVE
SEEN DURING THIS. AND DEMOCRATS-
SOME OF IT IS ALSO A AND IT
INTERACTED WITH HOUSING. FOR
EXAMPLE THERE IS A- ONE OF OUR
SISTER ORGANIZATIONS IN LA- DATA
CREATING CLIENT AND WHO BETTER
TO RENT A PLACE- BECAUSE SHE
WANTED TO LEAVE HER ABUSER SO
SHE HAD THE FUNDS HER RENTAL
BACKGROUND WAS FINE SHE THOUGHT
SHE HAD THE LEASE. UNTIL THE
COMPLEX THOUGHT SHE WOULD SPREAD
CODED BECAUSE SHE WAS ASIAN. SO
NOT HAVING STATE HOUSING
DEFINITELY AFFECTS ONE'S HEALTH
AND WELL BEING. OF OUR EVEN AS A
GUY THAT AFFECTED HAVE A DOUBLE
FEAR WALKING OUT THE DOOR AND
GETTING COLDER. BUT WITH THE
SECOND. PROBLEM BEING BEING
BLAMED FOR KOBE AND HAVING TO
DEAL WITH RACISM. HI AND IT
ISN'T ENOUGH THAT THERE IS THAT
REALITY OF THE FEAR INCOMPETENT
THE COVERED RACISM. THIS IS ALSO
BEEN- AWAY OF ABUSE BY THEIR
THEIR ABUSERS- WE'VE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL VICTIMS TELLING US HOW
THEIR ABUSERS TELL THEM. YOU
KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GET
COOPER THEY'RE GOING TO SPREAD
COLD WINTER GONNA FACE RACISM
AND SO IT JUST MAKES IT THAT
MUCH HARDER FOR THEM TO CHANGE
THEIR LIVES TO CALL FOR HELP.
AND WE'VE ALSO KNOWN THAT
THERE'S BEEN AN IMPACT
ESPECIALLY ON THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY. IT BAG
COMMUNITIES SUFFERED THE MOST
ECONOMICALLY BECAUSE I'VE CALLED
A COUPLE FEARS AND RACISM. THIS
IS MEANT A LOSS OF JOBS IN OUR-
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES STRESS ADDITIONAL
STRESS ON OUR API FAMILIES AND
WE BELIEVE MORE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN IN OUR HOMES. THE
VIRUS DIDN'T HAVE TO PHYSICALLY
TOUCH OUR FAMILIES BUT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT FROM THE
VERIFIERS MAY BE CONTRIBUTING TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN OUR
FAMILIES. SO IF THERE'S
SOMETHING LEGISLATIVE THAT YOU
COULD HELP WITH THIS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THAT IMPACTED BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE ESPECIALLY
REVEALED WHEN FOLKS RETURNED TO
WORKING OUTSIDE THEIR HOMES
MORE. AND THAT'S WHEN I CRISIS
CALLS WHICH ONES ARE GOING TO
SPIKE MARC AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN PLACE AND A
STRONGER POSITION. TO PROVIDE
EFFECTIVE SERVICE. THANK YOU
MISS THOMAS I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT I KNOW THAT- WE HAVE
BEEN REALLY FOCUSED ON THE RISE
SPECIFICALLY IN ASIAN HATE
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC IT'S SOMETHING THAT-
YOU KNOW WE- I AM A MEMBER OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS AND WE HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED WE FOCUS AT ALL
TIMES ON THE RISE IN HATE CRIMES
THAT AFFECTS OUR COMMUNITY BUT
IT IS BEEN- DISTINCT. HONOR TO
PARTNER WITH THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER CAUCUS TO REALLY LOOK
AT WHAT WE CAN DO TO IMPROVE.
THE SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE DID PASS QUITE A FEW PIECES
OF LEGISLATION LAST YEAR THAT WE
HOPE WILL HELP WITH THE
REPORTING AND TRACKING THOSE
HATE CRIMES WE CAN BETTER TARGET
THEM BUT IT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT
THING AND I'M REALLY GLAD YOU
ELEVATED IT. BECAUSE IT DOES
TOUCH EVERY ASPECT OF THE LIVES
OF THOSE WHO EXPERIENCE IT
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY
AB EXPERIENCING TRAUMA TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND THIS
MESSENGER ANYTHING YOU WANNA ADD. TO WHAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON. I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO MUCH OF WHAT- HILDA
HAS ALREADY LIFTED UP WHICH IS
THE NEED FOR CULTURALLY SPECIFIC
FUNDING- WE ARE WE ARE ONE SUCH
GRANT WE RECEIVED IT. AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BUT WE DON'T KNOW
OF ANY AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT
REALLY. ALLOCATE FUNDING
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE CHEN C.
CENTER LIKE. MY SISTER'S HOUSE
THAT ARE- OPERATING WITH THE
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC PLANS AND
FOCUS. PRECAMBRIAN MICK- AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN WERE. THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND WE
SUSPECT. THAT THAT STATISTIC-
HAS INCREASED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND WE KNOW THAT-
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN HAVE
PARTICULAR CONCERNS. ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO REACH OUT FOR HELP NOT
IN TRADITIONAL WAYS. AND OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS STOOD AS ONE OF
THOSE SAFE HAVENS WHERE. AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES FELT SAFE TO REACH OUT
FOR HELP. WHEN THEY WERE
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SO WE'D LIKE TO SEE FUNDING
THAT RECOGNIZES THE SPECIAL
ROLE. THAT WE PLAY IN SERVING
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES- I DID
TOUCH ON THIS A LITTLE BIT IN MY
OPENING REMARKS IN TERMS. OF.
LOOKING AT HOW. FINDING IT YOU
AND SUCCESS METRICS- SOME OF OUR
CONTRACTS ARE FEE FOR SERVICE SO
IN OTHER WORDS WE ONLY GET
REIMBURSED UNDER THE CONTRACT
WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO BILL FOR
CERTAIN. SPECIFIC SERVICES SUCH
AS BAD NIGHTS AND IN THE WAKE OF
THE PANDEMIC THESE METRICS NO
LONGER MAKES SENSE AND THEY
DON'T ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
BREADTH AND SCOPE OF THE WORK
THAT WE ARE DEALING I'M
PARTICULARLY IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC AND SO I BELIEVE LIKE
THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT PERHAPS. CRAFTING SOME
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD DO AWAY
WITH THESE- MEASUREMENT MODELS
IF YOU WILL THAT WILL HINDER OUR
ABILITY. AS SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
DO THIS WORK AND TO DO THIS WORK
IN A WAY THAT IS FLEXIBLE AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE. AND
THAT CAN ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO
FUNCTION NO MATTER WHETHER IT'S
A PANDEMIC OR SOMETHING ELSE
THAT- IMPACTS THE WAY THAT WE DO
THE WORK SO THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING I'D ASK LEGISLATORS TO
CONSIDER. IF I MIGHT ADD YOU
KNOW COBIT NINETEEN IS REALLY
DRAMATIZED RESULTS INSTEAD IN
EQUITIES IN OUR SYSTEM. AND
THERE ARE. COUNTERPARTS AND HAVE
BIG FUND RAISING TEENS- BUT
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY ABLE AND
EFFECTIVE TO SERVE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- INSIDE. I WANT TO
ECHO ALISON IS. COMMON IF YOU
KNOW MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
FUNDING FOR THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE HAVE THAT EXPERTISE
ESPECIALLY DEALING WITH LANGUAGE
AND CULTURAL ISSUES. AND I WANT
TO ECHO TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS THAT OTHER PROGRAMS- THAT
UTILIZE EXISTING FUNDED PROGRAMS
MAKE MEASURABLE PROGRESS TOWARDS
SERVING ALL OF THEIR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU BOTH I THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
SERVICES TO YOU- THE YOU ALL
PROVIDE AND YOUR PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS AND ENSURING THAT.
WE HAVE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
ORGANIZATIONS TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE
AND- MAKE SURE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE COMFORTABLE RIGHT I
MEAN THIS IS A HEART YOUR
CLIENTS TO REALLY HARD THING
WHEN THEY REACH OUT TO YOU FOR
SERVICES. AND SO I KNOW THAT
THEY NEED TRUST IN ORDER TO DO
THAT AND I KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE WORKED
INCREDIBLY HARD. AND TO EARN
THAT TRUST AND TO CONTINUE TO BE
A TRUSTED SOURCE TO PROVIDE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SERVICES
THAT SAVE A LIFE. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT. TO AND I
KNOW MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
CONTINUE. TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
SUPPORT ALL OF YOU AND SAVING.
THE LIVES WHO NEED IT MOST SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
FOR HIGHLIGHTING THE IMPORTANT
WORK WE HAVE AHEAD OF US- I
THINK THAT THIS HEARING HAS
REALLY- IT'S GONNA PUT US TO
WORK WITH A LOT TO DO BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT WORK AND IMPORTANT
WORK FOR. AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE SO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT WORK EVERY SINGLE
DAY. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO A
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP. IN THIS
WORK. I'M WITH FACTS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT IF
ANYONE IS CALLING IN. YOU MAY
CALL AND THE TOLL FREE NUMBER
LISTED ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WHICH IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO ALL
COMMENTS AND CAN BE UP TO TWO
MINUTES THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE TO
CONTRIBUTE. AND THERE IS NO ONE
HERE IN THE ROOM SO WE WILL NOT
TAKE ANY COMMENT IN PERSON- BUT
IF THE MODERATOR WILL SEE IF
ANYONE'S ON THE LINE THAT WOULD
BE GREAT. THANK YOU IF YOU LIKE
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME YOUR PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN WE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
DO HAVE A FEW LINES THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. IT'S LIKE TO PROCEED
TO THE FIRST COMMENT. YES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU GOLDLINE THE
ELEVEN ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY CAN I BE HEARD- IN
REPRODUCTIVE COMMITTEES- I
INTENDED TO COMMEND PERSON TODAY
BUT- GIVEN THAT- I AM JUGGLING-
A SICK CHILD AND CHILDREN WITH
NO SCHOOL IT'S A LITTLE BIT
IRONIC BECAUSE OF THE TOPIC- OF
TODAY'S HEARING YEAH AND I THINK
BIRD YOU ARE BEING HEARD YOU
ARE. ON THE PHONE FROM WORK
SOMETIMES PEOPLE CUT OUT
SOMETIMES SOME OF BOTH KALRA
ISN'T TAKEN AT ALL SO THAT BEING
SAID- MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD
STRUM AND- TOOK A LOT OF. THINGS
I COULD SEE ADDED KNOW WHAT
DIRECTION I WOULD TAKE MY
COMMENT TODAY- BECAUSE SOME OF
THESE ACCOUNTS ARE JUST SO
HEARTBREAKING ABOUT THE
DOMESTIC- BY ONCE AND- HOW THIS
HAS IMPACTED. WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR- THE ACCOUNT OF THE-
PEOPLE BEING DENIED- ABOUT-
EXPERIENCE- BECAUSE OF THESE-
STRUCTURES AND LOCKDOWNS AND-
IT'S JUST UNFATHOMABLE TO ME SO-
AGAIN I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
DIRECTION I WOULD TAKE MY
COMMENT BUT- I FEEL COMPELLED TO
SAY- BY STARTING OUT I AM VERY
PRO CHOICE. AND I CONSIDER
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES
TO BE PARAMOUNT TO MY OWN VALUE
SYSTEM AS A MARK OF A JUST
SOCIETY I PERSONALLY HAVE WORKED
IN THE MATERNAL CARE INDUSTRY AS
A BIRTH DOULA AND FREESTANDING
BIRTH CENTER. AND OF THE PRE AND
POST NATAL YOGA TEACHER-
ADDITIONALLY I PERSONALLY HAVE
BEEN SERVED BY PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IN FIVE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA AND I
HAVE AN UNWAVERING CONVICTION
THAT REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
INCLUDING ACCESS TO ABORTION
SERVICES IS A BASIC HUMAN RIGHT
I PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN PREGNANT
NINE TIMES. I HAVE FOUR LIVING
CHILDREN AND I HAVE HAD TWO
ABORTIONS WHICH IS TO SAY I HAVE
ELECTED TO TERMINATE TWO
PREGNANCIES. I CHOSE ABORTION
BECAUSE OF MY OWN CONVICTION NOT
BODILY SOVEREIGNTY IS THE
CORNERSTONE OF THE HUMAN
EXPERIENCE AND BODILY
SOVEREIGNTY IS FOUNDATIONAL TO
WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE CARE AND ABORTION.
A WOMAN RIGHT TO ABSOLUTELY.
OVER HER BODY IS ALSO REFLECTED
IN CALIFORNIA CODE TWO FOUR ONE
SEVEN ONE. RIGHT FOR ME TO
DECIDE WHAT HAPPENS TO MY OWN
BODY. THE LAW SAYS THAT I MAY
NOT BE COERCED INTO DOING
ANYTHING AGAINST MY WISHES.
PLEASE HOLD WHILE THE HOUSE
MUNOZ RUNS THE NATION IN TERMS
OF ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE AND
ABORTION SERVICES IT IS
PERPLEXING TO ME THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO LEADING THE
WAY IN TERMS OF VACCINE
MANDATES. WHERE VACCINES ARE
CONCERNED CURRENTLY DEMOCRATS IN
CALIFORNIA DO NOT SEEM TO CARE
ABOUT THEIR OWN SUPPOSED VALUES
BECAUSE MY BODY MY CHOICE
APPARENTLY DOES NOT APPLY TO
VACCINES I FIND THIS IS
CONNECTED TO BE INTELLECTUALLY
DISHONEST. HYPOCRITICAL AND VERY
LOW OF SOME IT IS NO WONDER THAT
YOU MIGHT LIVESTRONG CONCEIVE
WILL NEED TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PERSON AFTER TWO MINUTES SO WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITY. TO HEAR ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT. OPERATOR IF YOU
MOVE TO THE NEXT COLOR. OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE TWELVE
I'M TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
NUMBER ONE TWO. CAN I BE HEARD
IN COMMITTEE. MS HAD STRONG
LEADERS HAD YOUR TWO MINUTES
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PERSON
THANK YOU I DON'T SEE AN
ONSLAUGHT OF PEOPLE TRYING TO
CALL. AND THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
CENSORING CITIZENS IS
UNACCEPTABLE THE RULES OF THE
COMMITTEE OR TWO MINUTES PER
PERSON OPERATOR IF WE COULD SEE
IF ANYBODY ELSE IS ON THE LINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU THEN WE WILL. CLOSE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME. I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
JOINED US VIRTUALLY AND IN
PERSON FOR JOINING US TOAY FOR
THE SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING. ON
THE IMPACT O THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC ON REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
. TO BE CLEAR WE ARE NOT THROUGH
THE END OF THIS PANDEMIC AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE END OF ITS
LASTING IMPACTS ON WOMEN.
PREGNANT PEOPLE CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND TO BE HONEST ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE HOWEVER
LEARNED A LOT SINCE WE BEGAN
STRUGGLING AGAINST THIS PANDEMIC
IN MARCH OF LAST YEAR. IT I
THEIR DISCUSSIONS LIKE THIS THAT
WE WILL UNDERSTAND OUR STRENGTHS
AND OUR SHORTCOMINGS OF THE
STATE ENTER TO SUSTAINABLE PATH
FOR THEIR PRIORITIZE IS RESOURCE
INVESTMENTS AND WHOLE PERSON
CARE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WANTED DEEPLY
THANK EACH OF OUR PANELISTS FOR
THEIR TIME THEIR THOUGHTFULNESS
AND THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK THAT
THEY DO EVERY DAY TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE AND HEALTHY YOU HEARD THEIR
STORIES YOU HEARD THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING THEY ARE TRULY THE
HEROES OF THIS PANDEMIC. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER.
SUPERVISOR MITCHELL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO SENATOR RUBIO AND
OTHER MEMBERS WHO CONTINUE TO
SHOW ONGOING LEADERSHIP IN THESE
AREAS. WE MUST WORK AS AN ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE TACKLING THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED TODAY. AND I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA FOR JOINING IN THE
DISCUSSION AND FOR THOSE MEMBERS
WHO JOINED US REMOTELY. I AM
HONORED TO WORK ALONGSIDE EACH
AND EVERYONE OF THESE CHAMPIONS
FOR WOMEN AND MOTHERS. WITH THE
RIGHT TO ABORTION UNDER THREAT.
CALIFORNIA MAY WELL BE PROVIDING
REPRODUCTIVE CARE TOO MANY MORE
PEOPLE IN THE COMING YEARS WE
ARE PREPARED TO DO THAT AND WE
WILL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR
THE WOMEN OF THIS NATION.
UNDERSTANDING OUR SYSTEM IN OUR
PREPARE US TO INVEST WHERE IT IS
MOST NEEDED AND MAKING SURE THAT
NO ONE FALLS THROUGH THE CRACKS.
SO I WANT TO TANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING PARTNERS IN THIS WORK AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS ONGOING
DISCUSSION AND WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED.